ONE. WE ARE NOT IN SESSION. SO
THIS IS AN INFO HEARING. AT THIS
TIME, I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
GUYS FOR JOINING US FOR THE
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
CALIFORNIA SAFETY STRATEGY FOR
HOSTING MAJOR GLOBAL GAMES. I'D
LIKE TO GO OVER A COUPLE OF
HOUSEKEEPING RULES FOR THOSE OF
US JOINING IN PERSON. WE ARE IN
ROOM 1200 IN THE Þ STREET
BUILDING, AND WE ARE ALSO LIVE
STREAMING TODAY'S HEARING TO OUR
WITNESSES. PRESENTATIONS ARE
LIMITED TO ROUGHLY FIVE MINUTES
MAXIMUM PER WITNESS.
PRESENTATIONS ARE ORGANIZED PER
PANEL, SO FOLLOWING EACH PANEL
THERE WILL BE ROOM FOR QUESTIONS
AND ANSWERS AND A DISCUSSION
FROM THE MEMBERS AT THE DAIS.
BEFORE MOVING ON TO THE NEXT
PANEL, WE WILL BE TAKING PUBLIC
COMMENTS AT THE END OF THE
HEARING, AND I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT SEVERAL OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
SLATED TO JOIN US, BUT ARE A
LITTLE DELAYED. SO WE WILL START
WITHOUT THEM. AS WE LOOK AHEAD
TO THE SEVERAL HIGH ATTRACTION
GAMES THAT WILL BE HOSTED IN
CALIFORNIA, WE HAVE A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY AND RESPONSIBILITY
TO ENSURE THAT THE STATE IS
FULLY PREPARED TO HOST THESE
MAJOR EVENTS, WHILE UPHOLDING
THE HIGHEST STANDARD OF PUBLIC
SAFETY AND HUMAN RIGHTS. IN
PARTICULAR, I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THE WORLD CUP IS
PROBABLY THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
AND MOST IMPORTANT TO OUR STATE
FROM AN ECONOMIC STANDPOINT, BUT
ALSO JUST AN ENTERTAINMENT
STANDPOINT. IT HAS NOT BEEN
HOSTED IN THE UNITED STATES IN
OVER 30 YEARS, SO THAT IS THE
ONE THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
PRIORITIZING IN THIS PARTICULAR
HEARING. BUT IT ALSO PRESENTS
CHALLENGES THAT MUST BE
ADDRESSED WITH CAREFUL PLANNING,
COORDINATION AND TRANSPARENCY.
OUR GOAL TODAY IS TO ENSURE THAT
ALL RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS FROM
STATE AGENCIES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO HOST COMMITTEES
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE ALIGNED
IN THEIR EFFORTS TO PROTECT THE
SAFETY AND WELL-BEING OF
EVERYONE INVOLVED. THAT'S
INCLUDING THE PLAYERS, THE FANS,
THE WORKERS, THE TOURISTS,
RESIDENTS AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
WE ARE HERE TO DISCUSS THE
MEASURES BEING PUT IN PLACE TO
PREVENT RISKS RELATED TO CROWD
CONTROL, EMERGENCY RESPONSE,
DATA PRIVACY, HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND THE PROTECTION OF VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. IT IS ALSO
ESSENTIAL THAT OUR STATE
AGENCIES WORK COLLABORATIVELY
AND EFFECTIVELY TO MEET THESE
CHALLENGES IN A WAY THAT
PRIORITIZES HUMAN DIGNITY AND
RESPECT FOR CIVIL RIGHTS. WE ARE
JOINED TODAY BY REPRESENTATIVES
FROM SEVERAL KEY AGENCIES AND
ORGANIZATIONS WHO WILL PROVIDE
INSIGHTS INTO THEIR PREPARATIONS
FOR THIS EVENT. I ENCOURAGE AN
OPEN AND CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOG TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA LEADS THE
WAY IN DELIVERING A SAFE, SECURE
AND INCLUSIVE EXPERIENCE AT EACH
OF THESE GAMES. WITH THAT, I'D
LIKE TO THANK OUR PANELISTS FOR
BEING HERE, AND I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT OUR VERY FIRST PANEL.
NUMBER ONE, I DO JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE THREE PANELS, RIGHT. PANEL
ONE WILL BE THE HOST COMMITTEE
REPRESENTATIVES. PANEL TWO WILL
BE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
REPRESENTATIVES. PANEL THREE
WILL BE STATE AGENCY
REPRESENTATIVES. AND THEN WE
WILL CLOSE OUT WITH PUBLIC
COMMENTS. SO OUR FIRST PANEL AND
I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THIS.
WE MAY HAVE POWERPOINT
PRESENTATIONS FROM THESE
INDIVIDUALS AT THIS PARTICULAR
LECTERN. WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
THE PANELISTS SPEAK. IF YOU ARE
SPEAKING TOGETHER PLEASE COME
TOGETHER. AND THEN AS THE PANEL
IS CONCLUDED, THERE WILL BE
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS. IF NOT,
YOU CAN THEN GO BACK TO YOUR
SEAT AND WE WILL MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT PANEL. SO FOR PANEL ONE IS
THE HOST COMMITTEE
REPRESENTATIVES. IT'S EILEEN
JOHN MUHAMMAD, PRESIDENT AND
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
BAY AREA HOST COMMITTEE. AND
MARIA CAMACHO, GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS ADVISOR FROM THE LA
SPORTS AND ENTERTAINMENT
COMMISSION. PLEASE JOIN US HERE.
GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE TODAY TO TALK TO
YOU ABOUT ALL OF THE MAJOR
EVENTS THAT WILL BE OCCURRING IN
THIS GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THANK YOU TO ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS THAT JOINED US, AS WELL
AS THIS WILL BE A COLLECTIVE
EFFORT. WE ARE GOING TO BE IN A
REALLY AMAZING TIME IN THIS
STATE OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS, AND BEYOND. AS MENTIONED,
MY NAME IS EILEEN CHEN MUHAMMAD.
I AM THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
THE BAY AREA HOST COMMITTEE, A
RELATIVELY NEW ORGANIZATION IN
THE BAY AREA RESPONSIBLE FOR
HOSTING, BIDDING, EXECUTING
GLOBAL SPORTING EVENTS IN THE
BAY. I'M JOINED HERE BY MY
COLLEAGUE MARIA CAMACHO, WHO IS
REPRESENTING THE LA SPORTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT COMMISSION. THEY
HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR A LOT
LONGER THAN WE HAVE, AND WE RELY
ON OUR COUNTERPARTS IN LA AS
THEY LEAD THE WAY ON THIS
JOURNEY WITH US. IF WE CAN MOVE
TO THE NEXT SLIDE. AS MENTIONED,
CALIFORNIA WILL BE THE EPICENTER
OF SPORT, CULTURE AND
ENTERTAINMENT OVER A TWO YEAR
PERIOD, NOT EVEN INCLUDING THE
OLYMPIC AND PARALYMPIC GAMES
OVER THE NEXT TWO AND A HALF
YEARS. WE WILL HOST THE 2025 NBA
ALL STAR GAME IN THE BAY AREA
NEXT FEBRUARY. SUPER BOWL 60 IN
FEBRUARY OF 2026. THE 2026 NBA
ALL STAR GAME IN FEBRUARY OF
2026. THE FIFA WORLD CUP ACROSS
BOTH THE BAY AREA AND LA IN THE
SUMMER OF 2026, AND THEN SUPER
BOWL 61. IN FEBRUARY OF 2027.
THE BAY AREA AND LA WILL BE
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA AS ONE
OF ONLY TWO STATES THAT HAVE TWO
HOST CITIES FOR THE FIFA WORLD
CUP. THE OTHER ONE BEING TEXAS
AND THE BAY AREA WILL BE THE
ONLY REGION TO EVER HOST A FIFA
WORLD CUP AND A SUPER BOWL IN
THE SAME CALENDAR YEAR. IN THE
HISTORY OF TIME, AND LIKELY IN
THE FUTURE AS WELL. NEXT SLIDE.
THESE EVENTS ARE BID FOR RUN BY
AND THE REQUIREMENTS FULFILLED
BY TWO. NOT FOR PROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS, LA SEC AND THE
BAY AREA HOST COMMITTEE. BOTH
ENTITIES ARE REQUIRED TO FULFILL
HUNDREDS OF REQUIREMENTS
GOVERNED BY THE EVENT OWNERS, IN
THIS CASE, FIFA, THE NFL, AND
THE NBA, AND THESE LEAGUES AND
GOVERNING BODIES IMPORTANTLY DO
NOT SHARE ANY OF THEIR REVENUE
STRUCTURES WITH THESE NOT FOR
PROFIT ORGANIZATIONS. OUR ROLE
IS TO WORK WITH AND LOCALIZE
THESE EVENTS WITH A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS, MANY OF
WHICH YOU SEE IN THE ROOM TODAY.
AND BY DOING SO, BRING BOTH
POSITIVE ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
SOCIETAL IMPACT TO THE REGION.
EACH ORGANIZATION, IMPORTANT FOR
EVERYONE TO KNOW, HAS BUILT IN
SIGNIFICANT OPERATIONAL SECURITY,
LOGISTICS CAPACITY,
TRANSPORTATION AND MOBILITY
CAPACITY WITHIN ITS OWN
ORGANIZATION THROUGH FULL TIME
STAFF AND OR ADVISORS AND
CONSULTANTS. LET'S MOVE TO THE
NEXT SLIDE. AS SENATOR WAHAB
MENTIONED, OUR FOCUS TODAY WILL
PRIMARILY BE ON THE FIFA WORLD
CUP. IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT AS
ONE TAKEAWAY FOR TODAY TO KNOW
THAT NO TEMPLATE EXISTS FOR THIS
TOURNAMENT IN THIS COUNTRY.
THERE ARE TWO REASONS FOR THAT.
ONE, IT HAS BEEN A VERY LONG
TIME SINCE WE LAST HOSTED A FIFA
MEN'S WORLD CUP. IN THIS IN THIS
COUNTRY. AND THE WORLD HAS
CHANGED SIGNIFICANTLY SINCE THAT
TIME, SINCE 1994. THE SECOND
REASON FIFA THEMSELVES HAVE
NEVER IMPLEMENTED THIS KIND OF
EXPANSIVE TOURNAMENT BEFORE.
THREE COUNTRIES, 16 CITIES WITH
AN EXPANDED TOURNAMENT FOOTPRINT
IN TERMS OF NUMBER OF TEAMS,
ATHLETES, VIPS, HEADS OF STATE,
ETC. WE ACTUALLY, AS HOST
COMMITTEES WERE NOT AWARE OF
THESE CHANGES AND THE
EXPANSIVENESS OF THE FOOTPRINT
WHEN WE BID FOR THIS TOURNAMENT
MANY YEARS AGO. THESE CHANGES
OCCURRED, AS YOU CAN SEE FROM
THE TIMELINE IN FRONT OF YOU.
AFTER WE HAD ALREADY WON BID AND
WON AS HOST CITIES, A SECONDARY
POINT, BUT EQUALLY IMPORTANT FOR
THIS VERSION OF THE WORLD CUP,
THERE IS NO COORDINATED CENTRAL
ORGANIZATION THAT'S REPRESENTING
ALL 11 U.S. HOST CITIES. IN
1994, THERE WAS A CENTRAL
ORGANIZATION THAT WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR COORDINATING
WITH FIFA, RAISING THE REVENUES
REQUIRED, ETC. IN FACT, IN MOST
CASES, THERE IS A CENTRAL
NATIONALLY REPRESENTED
ORGANIZATION. IT HAPPENED IN
QATAR 22. IT'S HAPPENED IN PRIOR
VERSIONS OF THE WORLD CUP. AND
FOR THIS ONE, NO SUCH
ORGANIZATION EXISTS. U.S. SOCCER
IS NOT THE CENTRAL BODY THAT IS,
THAT IS GOVERNING THE WORLD CUP
ON BEHALF OF THE HOST CITIES.
FIFA IS WORKING DIRECTLY WITH
EACH HOST CITY AS IT MANAGES AND
PLANS THIS TOURNAMENT. GO AHEAD.
EXCELLENT. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. SO
RIGHTLY SO. WHEN PEOPLE THINK OF
THE BIGGEST GLOBAL SPORTING
EVENT, THEIR MINDS NATURALLY GO
TO THE OLYMPIC GAMES. ESPECIALLY
SINCE TODAY IT'S FRONT AND
CENTER FOR MOST CALIFORNIANS AND
THOSE OF US IN THE LA REGION. WE
ARE VERY, VERY EXCITED TO HOST
AND SEE WHAT THE LA 28 DOES FOR
AND BRINGS TO OUR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGION AND REGION IN
GENERAL. THE FIFA WORLD CUP
TAKES PLACE, HOWEVER, IN OUR
REGION BEFORE THE OLYMPIC AND
PARALYMPIC GAMES, PROVIDING AN
IMPORTANT PRECURSOR AND TEST
RUN, IF YOU WILL, FOR THE SUMMER
OF 2028. ALSO KEY TO NOTE IS
THAT FIFA WORLD CUP IS
SIGNIFICANTLY LARGER. THE
NATIONAL FOOTPRINT IS LARGER,
FANDOM IS LARGER, MORE OF THE
WORLD PLAYS THE SPORT, AND
EXPOSURE OF THE TOURNAMENT IS
MORE THAN TWICE THAT OF THE
OLYMPIC GAMES, AS SHOWN IN THE
SLIDE HERE. SADLY, TRULY, IF
SOMETHING GOES WRONG IN 2026,
IT'S NOT GOING TO BODE WELL FOR
US IN 2028. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
SO LET'S LOOK AT WHAT THIS
MASSIVE TOURNAMENT MEANS FOR
CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY. WE WILL
TOGETHER HOST 14 MATCHES
INCLUDING THE OPENING MATCH IN
THE UNITED STATES AT SOFI
STADIUM. WE WILL HOST AT LEAST
HALF A MILLION VISITORS BETWEEN
US US AND THE BAY AND BRING OVER
$1.2 BILLION OF ECONOMIC IMPACT
TO OUR REGIONS. NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. MATCHES WILL BE HOSTED
AT OUR NEW SOFI STADIUM, WHICH
IS NOT SO NEW ANYMORE, BUT IT
WAS OPENED IN 2020 AND WE WILL
HOST EIGHT MATCHES THERE. AS
MENTIONED, THE US PORTION OF THE
TOURNAMENT WILL BEGIN IN LA WITH
THE MEN'S NATIONAL TEAM PLAYING
FIRST IN OUR CITY AND IN
INGLEWOOD. I WANT TO SAY TO MY
FRIENDS FROM INGLEWOOD, THE EYES
OF THE WORLD WILL UNDOUBTEDLY BE
ON US FOR THIS MOMENTOUS
OCCASION. OF KEY IMPORTANCE HERE
ARE THE SIGNIFICANT SECURITY
NEEDS THAT LA AND THE REGION
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR AROUND
THIS OPENING MATCH. AS WE HOST
HEADS OF STATE AND OTHER LEADERS,
HIGHER LEVELS OF SECURITY, MUCH
LIKE THAT, WILL BE REQUIRED FOR
THE FINALS, WILL BE REQUIRED
WITH US AT THE FIRST OPENING
MATCH. IN ADDITION TO THE
OPENING MATCH, INGLEWOOD AND LOS
ANGELES WILL HOST ALSO HOST
THREE PLAYOFF GAMES, INCLUDING
TWO ROUND OF 32 GAMES AND A
QUARTERFINAL. OKAY, AND THE BAY
AREA WILL HOST SIX MATCHES AT
LEVI'S STADIUM. TOGETHER WITH
OUR FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES IN
THE CITY OF SANTA CLARA. THESE
WILL INCLUDE FIVE GROUP STAGE
MATCHES AND ONE PLAYOFF
ELIMINATION GAME. THE DIVERSITY
OF THE BAY MAKES IT A FAVORABLE
LOCATION FOR INTERNATIONAL TEAMS
AND VISITORS ALIKE. AND WHILE
THE US TEAM IS NOT SLATED TO
PLAY IN THE BAY DURING THE GROUP
STAGE, ALTHOUGH WE'RE HOPING
THEY MAKE AN APPEARANCE IN THE
ROUND OF 32 ELIMINATION GAME, WE
WILL SEE AS A RESULT, A NUMBER
OF INTERNATIONAL TEAMS AND
POTENTIALLY THEIR HEADS OF STATE
REPRESENTED AND VISITING OUR
REGION. THE FIFA WORLD CUP DRAW
WILL TAKE PLACE IN DECEMBER
2025. THIS IS WHEN WE'LL LEARN
ABOUT WHICH COUNTRIES WILL BE
PLAYING IN EACH OF OUR MARKETS.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. MY BIGGEST
TAKEAWAY AFTER WORKING IN SPORT
FOR TWO DECADES AND THAT I SHARE
WITH YOU TODAY, IS THAT THERE IS
NOTHING, NOTHING LIKE A FIFA
WORLD CUP. AND IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO ALL BE AWARE OF THE
UNIQUENESS OF ITS SPORT, THE
SPORT AND ITS FANDOM. FIRST OF
ALL, WE'VE SPOKEN ABOUT THIS
BEFORE. THE TOURNAMENT FOOTPRINT
WILL BE VAST AND LARGE. A
MAJORITY OF THE TOURNAMENT
OBVIOUSLY TAKES PLACE AT OUR
INDIVIDUAL STADIUMS, AT SOFI
STADIUM AND AT LEVI'S STADIUM,
BUT THAT WILL NOT BE THE ONLY
PLACE THAT WE WILL EXPERIENCE.
FANDOM. FIFA. FIFA TYPICALLY
REQUIRES, AND AS WE'RE WORKING
THROUGH IN EACH OF OUR CITIES,
FAN FESTS, WATCH PARTIES,
COMMUNITY CELEBRATIONS, AND WE
EXPECT BOTH REGIONS TO HAVE A
TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF VISITORS
AND RESIDENTS ALIKE THAT WILL
WANT TO BE INVOLVED IN THE
TOURNAMENT AND ENGAGE IN THE
TOURNAMENT IN SOME WAY. FAN
BEHAVIOR. I THINK ALL OF US HAVE
SEEN RECENTLY, BOTH IN THE US
AND INTERNATIONALLY, HOW AVID
AND ENGAGED THIS FAN BASE
ACTUALLY IS. THEY ARE PASSIONATE
AND THEY'RE VERY, VERY HIGHLY
LOYAL FAN BASE. THEY WILL
TRAVEL, THEY WILL ARRIVE EARLY,
THEY WILL LIKELY ESTABLISH
COUNTRY CELEBRATION ZONES. AND
ACCORDING TO THE LATEST
RESEARCH, FAN CULTURE HAS BECOME
MORE VIOLENT AND ABUSIVE IN
RECENT YEARS. IN THIS SPORT. WE
EXPECT SIGNIFICANT CROSS-STATE
TRAVEL. THE PROXIMITY OF MATCHES
BETWEEN THE BAY AREA AND LA IS
ACTUALLY QUITE TIGHT, SO THERE'S
A MATCH IN THE BAY. IT'S
FOLLOWED BY A MATCH IN LA,
THERE'S A BREAK AND SO ON AND SO
FORTH FOR THE NEXT FOR THE FIRST
TWO WEEKS OF THE TOURNAMENT. AND
SO WE EXPECT FANS TO TRAVEL
BETWEEN THE TWO CITIES QUITE
CONSISTENTLY THROUGHOUT THE
FIRST TWO WEEKS OF THE
TOURNAMENT. AND OF COURSE, THERE
IS GOING TO BE A CONSIDERABLE
NEED FOR VIP MANAGEMENT.
ATTENDEES WILL INCLUDE FIFA
SENIOR OFFICIALS, HIGHLY POPULAR
TEAMS AND PLAYERS, CORPORATE
EXECUTIVES, HEADS OF STATE, ETC.
AND DEPENDING ON THAT, FIFA
WORLD CUP DRAW, WE COULD HAVE
SOME HEADS OF STATE THAT WILL
REQUIRE MORE ATTENTION VERSUS
OTHERS. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. ON
THIS SLIDE YOU CAN START TO SEE
I KNOW IT'S SMALL, BUT YOU CAN
START TO SEE HOW THE MATCHES
START TO PLAY OUT. AS I
REFERENCED IN THE EARLIER SLIDE,
THE TWO BOTTOM CITIES THERE ARE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA AND LOS
ANGELES WILL SHOW HOW THE
MATCHES ARE STARTING TO LAND,
WITH A MATCH STARTING IN LOS
ANGELES, THEN THE BAY, A DAY OFF
LOS ANGELES AND THE BAY A DAY
OFF LOS ANGELES, ETC. AGAIN,
THAT STARTS TO SPEAK TO THE
CROSS-STATE TRAVEL AND THE
THINGS THAT WE WANT TO ACTUALLY
MAXIMIZE AS A REGION FROM A
TOURISM PERSPECTIVE, WE DO
BELIEVE PEOPLE WILL STOP IN
PLACES LIKE MONTERREY, IN THE
CITIES BETWEEN LOS ANGELES AND
THE BAY FROM A TOURISM
PERSPECTIVE, AND WE ACTUALLY
WANT TO ENCOURAGE THAT TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR. OUR BIGGEST AND MOST
IMPORTANT REQUIREMENT RIGHT NOW
IS AROUND SAFETY. AND THAT IS
WHAT WE'RE SPENDING THE BULK OF
OUR TIME TOGETHER WITH ALL OF
OUR AGENCY PARTNERS, EXCEPTIONAL
PLANNING AND EXECUTION WILL BE
REQUIRED TO MITIGATE PUBLIC
SAFETY, CYBER TERRORISM, ETC.
ALL OF WHICH HAS CHANGED
CONSIDERABLY SINCE 1994. WE ARE
ALSO SPENDING A CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT OF TIME ON ESTABLISHING A
TURNKEY MOBILITY PLAN, BOTH
CROSS-STATE BUT ALSO WITHIN OUR
OWN MARKETS. I KNOW THE BAY HAS,
DEPENDING ON WHO YOU ASK, 27 TO
29 TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES THAT
WE ARE TRYING TO COORDINATE AS
THIS FAN BASE WILL EXPECT A MASS
TRANSIT OPTION AS COMPARED TO
OTHER SPORTING EVENTS. WE WANT
TO MAXIMIZE TOURISM AND SUSTAIN
THE LEGACY AND THE IMPACT WE
BRING TO OUR REGION. NEXT SLIDE.
WE WILL NEED HELP. AGAIN, AS I
STARTED THIS PRESENTATION, WE
CANNOT DO THIS AS JUST TWO NOT
FOR PROFIT ORGANIZATIONS. WE
WILL REQUIRE A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS TO COME
ALONG THIS JOURNEY WITH US. WE
ARE WORKING WITH ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT TO EDUCATE AS MANY
STAKEHOLDERS AS POSSIBLE ON WHAT
LIES IN FRONT OF US AND THE
SUPPORT WE RECEIVED IN THE NEXT
3 TO 6 MONTHS WILL DICTATE HOW
THIS TOURNAMENT WILL LOOK LIKE
IN EACH OF OUR REGIONS. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU AND MAKING CALIFORNIA A BEST
IN CLASS REGION TO HOST MAJOR
SPORTING EVENTS AND ALLOW THE
WORLD TO SEE ALL THAT WE LOVE
ABOUT OUR GREAT STATE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS? SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU. AND GOOD TO
SEE MY GOOD FRIEND, MISS CAMACHO
HERE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU DO. YOU WERE JUST
SPEAKING OF SECURITY, AND I'M
JUST WANTING TO KNOW, IS THERE
ADEQUATE BUDGETING ALREADY? DO
YOU SEE FOR SECURITY, OR DO YOU
WILL YOU REQUIRE SOME HELP FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL?
WE WILL REQUIRE SOME HELP. IT
WILL BE A REQUEST THAT WE ASK
FROM OUR FEDERAL COUNTERPARTS.
ALL 11 HOST CITIES HAVE
REQUESTED SOME SUPPORT,
SPECIFICALLY AND PRIMARILY IN
THE AREA OF PUBLIC SAFETY. WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL ASK FOR STATE
MATCHING IN SOME WAY, SHAPE OR
FORM, AND WE WILL REQUIRE BOTH
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT AS WELL AS
LOCAL SUPPORT TO ENSURE THAT WE
MEET ALL OF OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
NEEDS. ALL RIGHT. I DO JUST WANT
TO ASK A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS AND
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE TRYING TO
PRIORITIZE THIS AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE FOR THE PUBLIC'S
BENEFIT. I DO WANT TO SAY THAT
THE CITY OF SANTA CLARA IS IN MY
DISTRICT, SO OBVIOUSLY I CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT THE SAFETY AND
MAKING SURE THAT THIS GOES WELL.
THE CITY OF INGLEWOOD, I
BELIEVE, IS IN SENATOR
BRADFORD'S DISTRICT, AND I'M
SURE HE FEELS THE SAME. WITH
THAT SAID, CONSIDERING THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME FIFA HAS RETURNED
TO CALIFORNIA IN MORE THAN 30
YEARS, HOW ARE THE PUBLIC SAFETY
IMPLICATIONS OF HOSTING THE
WORLD CUP IN CALIFORNIA?
DIFFERENT? IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT, COMPARED TO 30 YEARS
AGO, JUST OFF THE TOP OF YOUR
HEAD. I'M GOING TO START, BUT
I'M GOING TO ASK MY COLLEAGUES
WHEN THEY COME UP TO ACTUALLY
HELP ME ANSWER THAT QUESTION. I
THINK THE TOURNAMENT ITSELF AND
THE SPORT ON ITS OWN, HAVE
GAINED A SENSE OF POPULARITY
THAT WE DIDN'T SEE 30 YEARS AGO.
AND SO BEHAVIOR FOR EXAMPLE,
THAT WE SAW AT THE COPA AMERICA
LAST YEAR IN OUR CITY FOR SURE
IN IN SANTA CLARA. BUT EVEN AS
YOU SAW IT ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
IS DIFFERENT TYPES OF BEHAVIOR,
RIGHT? AND SO THAT FAN BEHAVIOR,
THE PERMISSION OR SEEM SEEMINGLY
APPROPRIATE OR NOT APPROPRIATE
PERMISSION OF PLAYERS TO SORRY
FANS TO ACT IN A CERTAIN WAY
THAT HAS DEFINITELY CHANGED. WE
ARE HOSTING IT AT DIFFERENT
STADIUMS THIS TIME AROUND,
RIGHT? THE CAPACITY OF LEVI'S
STADIUM IS SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
THAN WHERE WE HOSTED IN THE
PAST, AND SO JUST HAVING THAT
MASS NUMBER OF PEOPLE COMING TO
A VENUE IS DIFFERENT. THAT BEING
SAID, WE'RE WORKING IN A IN A
CITY THAT KNOWS HOW TO DO THESE
EVENTS. I SPENT TIME WITH
CAPTAIN FITTING AND HIS TEAM
YESTERDAY AT A 40 NINERS GAME.
THEY WALKED ME THROUGH VERY
METICULOUSLY THEIR OPERATIONAL
MODEL, THEIR COMMAND STRUCTURE
MODEL, AND I FEEL GOOD THAT THE
REPS THAT THEY HAVE, THEY'VE
DONE THIS BEFORE. I KNOW THE
SAME THING EXISTS AT SOFI
STADIUM THAT WE'RE NOT WORKING
AND STARTING FROM SCRATCH AS
MAYBE WHAT DID HAPPEN IN 1994.
WE HAVE WELL USED STADIUMS WITH
WELL-RUN PRACTICES THAT WE WILL
RELY ON TO REALLY MAKE THIS
THING COME TOGETHER. YEAH. AND I
THINK TO THAT POINT, WE HAVE
PARTNERS HERE THAT WE'RE ALL IN
IT TOGETHER. SO WE'RE EXCITED TO
PUT ON SOMETHING THAT WE'RE USED
TO, BUT ALSO SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE READY TO BE CREATIVE AND
NIMBLE ON. OKAY. AND ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE OBVIOUSLY,
IT'S NOT JUST IN THE CITY OF
SANTA CLARA, BUT THE GAMES,
INCLUDING SEVERAL OF THE OTHER
GAMES WILL BE IN OAKLAND. IT
WILL BE, YOU KNOW, THERE WILL BE
FAN ZONES IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
IN OTHER PARTS OF THE BAY AREA.
SAN JOSE, A LOT, A LOT OF OUR
MAJOR CITIES AND JUST, YOU KNOW,
MAKING SURE THAT, YOU KNOW,
TRANSPORTATION IS OBVIOUSLY ONE
OF THE BIG CONCERNS AS WELL.
CORRECT? THAT'S RIGHT. SO
THERE'S TWO POINTS THERE THAT I
WILL MENTION THE FIRST IS OUR
HOPE. AND ACTUALLY THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US IS TO EXPAND
THE ACCESS TO THIS TOURNAMENT AS
WIDELY AS POSSIBLE. MOST OF THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THE BAY
ACTUALLY WON'T GO TO A FIFA
WORLD CUP MATCH, AND SO IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
THE CITIZENS OF THE BAY AREA IN
ALL NINE COUNTIES, THE SAME AS
LÀ, ARE EXPERIENCING THE
TOURNAMENT, NO MATTER WHERE THEY
LIVE AND WHETHER OR NOT THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO A MATCH OR NOT.
AND SO WE'RE ENCOURAGING
ACTIVATION AND ENGAGEMENT IN THE
COMMUNITIES OUTSIDE OF, YOU
KNOW, SANTA CLARA. AS MUCH AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN. AS I MENTIONED,
THIS FAN THAT COMES IN,
ESPECIALLY INTERNATIONAL WILL
EXPECT A MASS TRANSIT SOLUTION.
THAT'S HOW THEY BEHAVE NORMALLY
FOR A SOCCER MATCH. AND SO WE
ARE WORKING RIGHT NOW TO PUT
TOGETHER THAT TYPE OF MASS
TRANSIT TRANSPORTATION PLAN THAT
ALLOWS REALLY SEAMLESS FARE
INTEGRATION, TURNKEY OPERATIONS
DEPENDING NO MATTER WHAT TRAIN
THAT YOU GET UP AND OFF OF AND
TO MAKE THE TRANSIT ACTUALLY
PART OF THE OVERALL EXPERIENCE
AS WELL. OKAY. AND THEN DO YOU.
DOES YOUR ORGANIZATION OVERALL I
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THIS AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE. HAVE ZERO
AUTHORITY AND HAVE TO DEFER
COMPLETELY TO THE STATE IN
REGARDS TO PUBLIC SAFETY, OR DO
THEY HAVE, YOU KNOW, THEIR OWN
STANDARDS AND PROTOCOLS THAT
MUST BE MET, LIKE DOES FIFA HAVE
ANY CERTAIN PUBLIC SAFETY
STANDARDS THAT BASICALLY NEED TO
BE MET? YEAH, THERE ARE FIFA HAS
ESTABLISHED 18 DIFFERENT
SECURITY RELATED WORKING GROUPS.
MANY OF WHICH I THINK SOME OF
OUR COUNTERPARTS HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN ALREADY. AND WE
RECEIVED, I DON'T KNOW, A
THOUSAND REQUIREMENTS AS PART OF
THE BID PROCESS THAT WE WERE
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO MANAGE
AGAINST THAT BEING SAID, SENATOR
WAHAB, RIGHT. EVERY MARKET HAS
THEIR WAY OF DOING THINGS, AND
THAT LEVEL OF EXPERTISE ACTUALLY
HAS TO COME BACK AND FLOW
THROUGH FIFA TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE SAFETY AND SECURITY PLAN IS
ACTUALLY LOCALIZED TO THAT
MARKET AS WELL. OKAY. AND THEN
MY BIGGEST CONCERN IS, YOU KNOW,
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF THESE BIG
GAMES, WHETHER IT'S THE SUPER
BOWL AND SO FORTH THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES. AND IT ALWAYS
SEEMS TO BE A HUMAN RIGHTS AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKING ISSUE ATTACHED
TO THESE GAMES. RIGHT. AND I
JUST WANT TO UNDERSTAND, YOU
KNOW, WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
EFFORTS THAT YOUR ORGANIZATION
IS TRYING TO COMBAT SOME OF THIS
COMMITTEE? YEAH. SO PART OF
FIFA'S THOUSAND REQUIREMENTS IS
TO ACTUALLY ESTABLISH A HUMAN
RIGHTS ACTION PLAN. AND SO WE
ARE BOTH IN EARLY STAGES, BUT IN
STAGES OF PUTTING TOGETHER WHAT
THAT PLAN LOOKS LIKE, IT WILL
INCLUDE EXPERTS IN OUR SPECIFIC
MARKET THAT ACTUALLY DEAL WITH
THIS ON A DAY TO DAY BASIS,
INCLUDING LAW ENFORCEMENT. SO WE
ARE WE WILL HAVE TO PUT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT TOGETHER.
AND THAT HAS ACTUALLY STARTED
ALREADY THAT THAT PLANNING HAS
STARTED ALREADY. PERFECT. ALL
RIGHT. I DO APPRECIATE I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. I
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO PANEL NUMBER
TWO, WHICH IS LOCAL GOVERNMENT
REPRESENTATIVES. WE'RE FIRST
GOING TO HEAR FROM I APOLOGIZE
IF I MISPRONOUNCED THE NAME MARK
TERADA, CHIEF OF POLICE OF CITY
OF INGLEWOOD. AND THEN LATER
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM JOVAN
GROGAN, CITY MANAGER OF CITY OF
SANTA CLARA, AND THEN DOUG
ARNOTT, SENIOR ADVISOR FOR
OPERATIONS FOR THE LA SPORT AND
ENTERTAINMENT COMMISSION. THANK
YOU MARK. APPRECIATE IT. WELL
THANK YOU. AND THAT WAS A GREAT
PRONUNCIATION. I APPRECIATE
THAT. AND GOOD MORNING TO THE
STAFF, SENATOR BRADFORD. GOOD TO
SEE YOU AGAIN. I KNOW YOU HAD A
WONDERFUL EVENT ABOUT A WEEK AGO
OR SO, AND SO AS IT RELATES TO
THE UPCOMING FIFA WORLD CUP
GAMES IN INGLEWOOD AND SANTA
CLARA, I STARTED SPEAKING TO THE
NEWLY ELECTED CHIEF HERE A
MINUTE AGO. YOU KNOW, IN
INGLEWOOD, OBVIOUSLY, WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH ANY GREAT EVENT
LIKE THIS, AND WE'RE CERTAINLY,
WELL, PREPARING FOR IT AS WE
SPEAK. WE HAVE HOSTED WORLDWIDE
EVENTS IN THE PAST FOR MANY
YEARS IN INGLEWOOD AND SO THE
BLUEPRINT THAT WE USE TO WORK
THESE EVENTS AND, AND BRING A
LEVEL OF PUBLIC SAFETY IS REALLY
SOMETHING WE HAVE WELL
ESTABLISHED THAT BLUEPRINT IS
THE SAME WE'VE USED FOR SUPER
BOWLS. IT'S THE SAME WE'LL USE
FOR FIFA, ANOTHER SUPER BOWL,
AND CULMINATING WITH THE
OLYMPICS IN 2028. AND THE WHAT I
HEARD REFERENCE TO A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS TO THE PREVIOUS
PRESENTERS. YOU KNOW, IN TERMS
OF OUR PREPARATION, WE HAVE A
GREAT WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH
OUR STATE, LOCAL AND FEDERAL
PARTNERS AND THE LA COUNTY
REGION AND WE'RE ALREADY WE ARE
MEETING ALREADY TALKING ABOUT
THESE EVENTS AND PLANNING FOR
THEM, DEALING WITH SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT YOU BROUGHT UP,
SENATOR, IN TERMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND THOSE ASPECTS OF
IT, WHICH UNFORTUNATELY COME
ALONG WITH THESE TYPES OF
EVENTS. BUT WE HAVE ELEMENTS AND
WE DETAIL SUBCOMMITTEES AND
FOLKS TO PAY ATTENTION TO THAT
AND WORK THAT AGAIN WITH OUR
LOCAL PARTNERS AND FEDERAL
PARTNERS AS WELL. SO WE BRING IN
A MUTUAL AID CONCEPT, AND UNDER
THE INCIDENT COMMAND SYSTEM,
WHICH IS BREAD AND BUTTER IN OUR
PROFESSION, AND IT WORKS WELL
AND WE'VE USED IT AND WE'LL
EXPAND IT FOR THIS EVENT. AND I
FEEL VERY CONFIDENT THAT WE'LL
BE ABLE TO MEET THIS DEMAND.
THANK YOU. APPRECIATE IT. DO WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS? YOU KIND OF
TOUCHED ON IT, BUT I'M JUST
SAYING THE LEVEL OF
COLLABORATION WITH THE
SURROUNDING LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES, THERE IS A
BLUEPRINT ALREADY ESTABLISHED,
OR YOU'RE BUILDING OUT WITH THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
YES, SENATOR, WE HAVE A
BLUEPRINT, AND WE'VE USED IT FOR
MANY YEARS NOW, AND WE'RE
OBVIOUSLY BE BIGGER FOR FIFA.
AND ALSO THE OLYMPICS. AND YES,
THAT'S ALREADY IN PLACE. AND
BEING BUILT OUT, I SHOULD SAY A
LOT OF IT'S BEING BUILT OUT AS
WE SPEAK. AND IS IT ANY NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S GOING TO BE
USED AS FAR AS SECURITY, SUCH AS
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE OR
FACIAL RECOGNITION, WILL THAT BE
PART OF THE OVERALL SECURITY
PROTOCOLS? YEAH, I HOPE SO.
WE'RE A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT, AS
YOU KNOW, THAN SANTA CLARA
BECAUSE THAT'S A PRIVATELY OWNED
VENUE. HOWEVER, YOU KNOW, WE
KNOW WORKING WITH SOFI STADIUM
AND THE, YOU KNOW, THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT THEY HAVE AND WE
HOPE TO ENHANCE THAT. WE'RE
LOOKING AT SOME THINGS
INTERNALLY. WE'RE PILOTING SOME
THINGS IN THE CITY RIGHT NOW
THAT I'M VERY HOPEFUL WILL PAY
SOME BENEFITS. I BELIEVE IT WILL
WHEN THAT TIME COMES. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO JOVAN GROGAN, THE
CITY MANAGER OF SANTA CLARA. ALL
RIGHT. BEFORE WE BEGIN, CAN WE
TRANSFER TO HIS SLIDES? ALL
RIGHT. OKAY. GOOD MORNING, AND
THANK YOU TO SENATOR WAHAB FROM
OUR HOME DISTRICT TEN, IN SANTA
CLARA. AND NICE TO SEE YOU,
SENATOR BRADFORD. JOVAN GROGAN,
CITY MANAGER OF SANTA CLARA. AND
I HAVE A FEW SLIDES THAT I WILL
PRESENT TO YOU TODAY. I'M HERE
NOT BY MYSELF. I AM HERE WITH
POLICE CHIEF ELECT COREY MORGAN,
WHO WILL BE THE POLICE CHIEF
DURING 2026. I'M HERE WITH
CAPTAIN RICHARD FITTING, WHO IS
OUR COMMANDER AT LEVI'S STADIUM
AND WAS THE COMMANDER AT
YESTERDAY'S GAME WITH THE
SEAHAWKS, AS WELL AS ASSISTANT
CITY MANAGER CHUCK BAKER, WHO
HAS MORE DAY TO DAY OVERSIGHT
OPERATIONS FOR OUR STADIUM
AUTHORITY. NEXT SLIDE. AS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT IN 2026, LEVI'S
STADIUM IN SANTA CLARA IS
SCHEDULED TO HOST A SERIES OF
MAJOR EVENTS SUPER BOWL 60, IN
FEBRUARY AND SIX FIFA WORLD CUP
GAMES BEGINNING IN JUNE. 13TH
THROUGH JULY. FIRST LEVI'S
STADIUM, WHICH OUR MASTER TENANT
TENANT IS THE 40 NINERS. LEVI'S
STADIUM IS ACTUALLY OWNED BY THE
SANTA CLARA STADIUM AUTHORITY, A
PUBLIC ENTITY THAT WAS FORMED BY
THE CITY OF SANTA CLARA IN 2011.
IT REALLY A TRULY AMAZING
REGIONAL ASSET AND THE PREMIER
OUTDOOR STADIUM IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THE STADIUM
AUTHORITY CONTRACTS WITH THE 40
NINERS MANAGEMENT COMPANY FOR
DAY TO DAY OPERATIONS, BOTH FOR
THE NFL SEASON AND WHAT WE CALL
THE NON NFL EVENT SEASON. SO SIX
MONTHS, SIX MONTHS. THE SANTA
CLARA POLICE DEPARTMENT IS THE
LEAD PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCY FOR
LEVI'S STADIUM, RESPONSIBLE FOR
PLANNING AND OPERATIONAL
IMPLEMENTATION. OVER THE LAST 18
MONTHS, THE CITY OF SANTA CLARA
HAS BEEN WORKING COLLABORATIVELY
WITH THE BAY AREA HOST
COMMITTEE. THE 40 NINERS, THE
NFL, FIFA, THE U.S. CONFERENCE
OF MAYORS, FBI, DHS, THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL,
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD, AND
CAL OES, AS WELL AS VARIOUS
OTHER PARTNERS TO BEGIN PLANNING
FOR THESE MAJOR EVENTS THAT WILL
OCCUR IN OUR CITY AND REALLY
BENEFIT THE ENTIRE REGION. NEXT
SLIDE. SO A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
LEVI'S STADIUM OPENED IN 2014.
LEVI'S STADIUM HAS HOSTED OVER
200 MAJOR EVENTS WITH 9 MILLION
PLUS ATTENDEES. IT IS IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT WE HAVE HOSTED A
NUMBER OF MAJOR NON NFL EVENTS,
BUT ALSO WANT TO NOTE WE HOSTED
SUPER BOWL 50 BACK IN 2016. SO
TEN YEARS FROM WHEN WE'RE
SCHEDULED TO HOST SUPER BOWL 60.
WE'VE HOSTED SIX TAYLOR SWIFT
GAMES, BEYONCE CONCERT,
WRESTLEMANIA, NFC CONFERENCE
CHAMPIONSHIPS, AS WELL AS COPA
AND GOLD CUP, INTERNATIONAL
SOCCER MATCHES. IMPORTANT TO
NOTE WE ARE SAFETY ACT
DESIGNATED BECAUSE WE EMPLOY
SPECIALIZED TECHNOLOGY TO COMBAT
TERRORISM. WE ALSO FREQUENTLY
MEET AND EXCEED THE NFL BEST
PRACTICE STANDARDS FOR STADIUM
SECURITY AND FAN CONDUCT. NEXT
SLIDE. AS THE SMALLEST CITY IN
THE U.S. WITH A MAJOR NFL
STADIUM, WE DON'T DO THIS ALONE.
IN FACT, WE PARTNER WITH OVER 70
FEDERAL, STATE, AND REGIONAL
POLICING AGENCIES FROM ACROSS
CALIFORNIA TO SUPPORT NORMAL
OPERATIONS AT LEVI'S STADIUM. WE
EMPLOY BOTH PER DIEM STAFF, SO
STAFFING FROM OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN THE
REGION AND FRANKLY, ACROSS
CALIFORNIA, THAT SUPPORT LEVI'S
STADIUM ON A REGULAR BASIS. JUST
AS A NOTE, OUR REGULAR SWORN
STAFFING RATIO FOR A REGULAR NFL
EVENT THAT OCCURRED IN OCTOBER
OF THIS YEAR, ONLY 23% OF THE
STAFF WERE ACTUALLY FROM THE
CITY OF SANTA CLARA, AND 77%
WERE FROM ALLIED PARTNERS OR PER
DIEM OFFICERS. SO TRULY A STATE
WIDE EFFORT TO SUPPORT LEVI'S
STADIUM. NEXT SLIDE. ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE DOING THIS, WE
HAVE IMPLEMENTED A NUMBER OF
COST OPTIMIZATION MEASURES OVER
THE YEARS. WE WE'VE CONVERTED
SOME OF OUR NOT OUR SWORN STAFF
TO NON-SWORN POSITIONS TO SAVE
ON COSTS. WE HAVE A LAYERED
APPROACH TO WHERE GUEST SERVICES
AND SECURITY ARE THE FIRST LINE
BEFORE SWORN LAW ENFORCEMENT. WE
ALSO HAVE AN ONGOING EFFORT TO
RECRUIT PER DIEM OFFICERS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE AND SO AGENCIES
UP AND DOWN, UP AND DOWN THE
STATE. WE ARE ON THE SLIDE, A
FLIER WHERE WE'RE REGULARLY
LOOKING FOR PEOPLE TO SUPPORT
THIS EFFORT. NEXT SLIDE. WE KNOW
THAT WE ARE BUT ONE SMALL
COMPONENT OF THE FINANCIAL
ASSETS THAT WILL BE BEFORE THE
STATE. HOWEVER, I DID WANT TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH JUST A HIGH
LEVEL SUMMARY OF OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY COSTS FOR THE CITY OF
SANTA CLARA, AND THAT'S LEVI'S
STADIUM. IMPORTANT TO NOTE THESE
ARE NOT REALLY ALL CITY OF SANTA
CLARA COSTS. WE ARE
APPROXIMATELY 25% ON A NORMAL
DAY FOR A MAJOR EVENT. OUR OUR
STAFFING WILL COULD BE IN THE
TEENS IF NOT THE SINGLE DIGITS.
AND SO WE'VE WORKED OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS TO DEVELOP
PUBLIC SAFETY COST ESTIMATES FOR
BOTH THE FIFA WORLD CUP GAMES AS
WELL AS SUPER BOWL 60. THOSE ARE
ON THE SCREEN. IT'S RESPECTIVELY
12 JUST OVER $12 MILLION FOR
FIFA WORLD CUP AND 7.5 MILLION
FOR SUPER BOWL, WITH AN
ESTIMATED TOTAL OF JUST UNDER 20
MILLION OVER THE NEXT 12 TO 18
MONTHS. A NUMBER OF ITEMS WILL
COME INTO VIEW AND IMPACT THESE
COST ESTIMATES. WE WILL
PERIODICALLY BE UPDATING THESE
ESTIMATES, BUT WE WILL WORK WITH
THE BAY AREA HOST COMMITTEE, OUR
FEDERAL AND STATE PARTNERS, AS
WELL AS THE NFL AND FIFA WORLD
CUP, WHO ARE ACTUALLY THE OWNERS
OF THE EVENT AS JAN MOHAMMED
MENTIONED. AND SO AS THE
SECURITY PERIMETER IS FINALIZED,
AS THE MODES OF TRANSPORTATION
TO AND FROM THE STADIUM ARE
FINALIZED, AS WELL AS PATHWAYS
TO THE CITY FROM THE LARGER
REGION, THAT WILL CERTAINLY
IMPACT OUR PLANNING EFFORTS AND
MAY ADJUST THESE NUMBERS. ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT OUR
POSTURE ON SECURITY MAY CHANGE
IF THERE IS AN INTERNATIONAL
TERRORIST INCIDENT LEADING UP TO
THE GAMES. LASTLY, IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE TEAMS
THAT WILL PLAY AT LEVI'S STADIUM
AND THEIR FAN BASE IS A MAJOR
CONSIDERATION. AND SO AS WE ALL
KNOW, THOSE TEAMS WILL NOT BE
KNOWN FOR SEVERAL MONTHS. THAT
CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION. I
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
HAVING THIS SESSION, AND I'M
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SO I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
CONCERNS. NUMBER ONE, I DO JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT FOR THE PUBLIC
AND THOSE WATCHING THIS INFO,
HEARING THAT THESE NUMBERS ARE
NOT FINALIZED AT ALL. NUMBER ONE
AND THEY ARE BEING REVIEWED
VIGOROUSLY. AND THERE HAS NOT
BEEN AN AGREEMENT MADE BETWEEN
THE NFL, FIFA OR I SHOULD SAY
THE HOST COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
THE CITY OF SANTA CLARA. CORRECT?
YES, WE ARE OKAY. SO SINCE THERE
IS NOT AN AGREEMENT YET, I
BELIEVE THAT THESE NUMBERS ARE
GOING TO BE FLUCTUATING. AND I
WANT TO PRIORITIZE THE FACT THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PUBLIC
SAFETY. BEFORE WE TALK ABOUT
BUDGETARY COSTS. BUT I DO HAVE A
CONCERN IN REGARDS TO THE
HOMELESS POPULATION AROUND THESE
VENUES. WHAT IS THE LOCAL CITIES
PLAN FOR POTENTIALLY DEALING
WITH IT? ABSOLUTELY. SO THANK
YOU, SENATOR WAHAB. WE ARE
FORMULATING THOSE PLANS AS WE
SPEAK. WE DO HAVE A GRANT FROM
THE STATE FOR $1.8 MILLION FOR
HOMELESS, HOMELESS SERVICES. WE
ARE CURRENTLY LOOKING INTO SAFE
RV PARKING SITES. AND AS YOU
KNOW, WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
HOMELESS ISSUE. NOT JUST IN OUR
AREA, BUT BUT IN THE REGION. AND
SO WE ARE FORMULATING PLANS. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE LEAD WITH
IS COMPASSION. AND SO OUR
APPROACH WILL BE COMPASSIONATE.
BUT WE REALLY, IN THE CITY OF
SANTA CLARA, ARE REALLY
RETOOLING ALL OF OUR HOMELESS
EFFORTS. WE RECENTLY APPOINTED A
DEPUTY CITY MANAGER TO OVERSEE
ALL OF OUR HOMELESS EFFORTS, TO
KNIT TOGETHER ALL OF THE WORK
THAT ALL OF OUR DEPARTMENTS DO
TO REALLY LEAD WITH COMPASSION.
BUT BUT KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT NOT JUST FOR THESE
MAJOR EVENTS, BUT SIGNIFICANT
QUALITY OF LIFE ISSUES FOR BOTH
THOSE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
AND OUR RESIDENTS THAT WE NEED
TO GRAPPLE WITH ON A DAILY,
DAILY BASIS. DEFINITELY FOR THE
CITY. WHAT IS THE EXPECTED
NUMBER OF, LET'S SAY, FANS SLASH
TOURISTS THAT WILL COME IN TO
THE CITY AROUND THAT TIME? YEAH,
I DON'T HAVE THOSE NUMBERS. I
WILL TELL YOU THAT LEVI'S
STADIUM SEATS APPROXIMATELY
70,000 68,500, AND WE NORMALLY
HAVE SELL OUT GAMES. SANTA CLARA
HAS LEVI'S STADIUM, BUT THE
ENTIRE BAY AREA REGION WILL BE
ACTIVATED. AND SO WE DO
CERTAINLY EXPECT FANS TO COME TO
SANTA CLARA THAT ARE NOT
ATTENDING THE GAME. AND OUR
SAFETY PLANS WILL ADDRESS THAT.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE WILL
BE A SIGNIFICANT FAN BASE IN SAN
JOSE, IN SAN FRANCISCO AND IN
OAKLAND. IT WAS MENTIONED IN
YOUR SLIDES. YOU GUYS HAD SIX
TAYLOR SWIFT CONCERTS AND A
BEYONCE CONCERT. DON'T TELL MY
DAUGHTER. YES. AND DO YOU OFTEN
SEE FROM A CITY PERSPECTIVE THAT,
YOU KNOW, YOUR HOTELS ARE FILLED
UP AND ALL OF THAT OR HOW DOES
IT WORK? ABSOLUTELY. IT IS ONE
OF THE MAJOR ECONOMIC BENEFITS
TO THE CITY FROM THE STADIUM. WE
DON'T HAVE A MAJOR MALL. WE HAVE
A LITTLE SLICE OF VALLEY FAIR,
BUT WE DO GET SIGNIFICANT
REVENUE FROM HOTELS. WE ARE
EXPECTING TO SELL OUT OF OUR
HOTELS AROUND BOTH OF THESE
MAJOR EVENTS. OKAY. AND THEN
FROM A TRANSPORTATION
PERSPECTIVE, FROM THE PREVIOUS
PANEL, WE HEARD THAT OBVIOUSLY
PEOPLE WANT PUBLIC TRANSIT, YOU
KNOW, HOW IS THAT BEING
ORGANIZED FROM A CITY
PERSPECTIVE, ESPECIALLY A SMALL
CITY THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
HAVE AS MANY BART STATIONS AS
WE'D PREFER OR SOMETHING ELSE?
ABSOLUTELY. WE DON'T HAVE A BART
STATION, AND THE CITY DOES NOT
OPERATE A TRANSIT ENTITY. AND SO
WE WILL CERTAINLY BE PARTNERING
WITH THE BAY AREA HOST COMMITTEE,
WHO HAS THE RESPONSIBILITY AND
THE LEADERSHIP ROLE FOR KNITTING
TOGETHER ALL OF THE REGIONAL
TRANSIT AGENCIES AROUND LEVI'S
STADIUM. WE ARE PARTNERING WITH
VTA. AS YOU KNOW, THERE IS A VTA
LIGHT RAIL LINE THAT RUNS RIGHT
IN FRONT OF THE STADIUM DURING
SUPER BOWL 50, THAT THAT LINE
WAS NOT ACTIVE. AND SO THERE WAS
A HARD PERIMETER AROUND. AND SO
WE ARE WORKING THROUGH ALL OF
THOSE PLANS AND MORE THINGS WILL
COME INTO VIEW OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL MONTHS. OKAY. AND THEN
WHAT IS YOUR IF YOU COULD BE
VERY BLUNT ABOUT IT, WHAT IS THE
ASK FROM THE STATE? SURE. SO THE
CITY OF SANTA CLARA IS REALLY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE BAY AREA
HOST COMMITTEE FOR THE FINANCIAL
ASK KNOWING THAT THERE IS YES,
THE EVENTS AT LEVI'S STADIUM,
BUT ALL OF THE EVENTS ACROSS THE
BAY AREA REGION AND ACROSS THE
STATE. AND SO WE ARE WE ARE
PARTNERED WITH A GLOBAL ASK. I
WILL SAY, AND YOU NOTED EARLIER
THAT THE COST HAVE NOT BEEN
AGREED TO. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT WE ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF FINALIZING WHAT'S CALLED AN
ASSIGNMENT AND ASSUMPTION
AGREEMENT, WHERE WE WILL
FORMALLY ASSIGN FIFA WORLD CUP
TO THE BAY AREA HOST COMMITTEE,
AND THEY WILL ESSENTIALLY BE A
TENANT TO PUT ON THOSE GAMES
WHILE WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
PROCESS OF NEGOTIATING THAT
THERE IS NOT A HARD DOLLAR
AMOUNT FOR PUBLIC SAFETY BECAUSE
WE CANNOT PLACE A HARD DOLLAR
AMOUNT FOR PUBLIC SAFETY. THE
PUBLIC SAFETY OPERATIONAL PLANS
AND DEPLOYMENT WILL REALLY BE
BASED ON THE KNOWN THREATS AT
THAT TIME. AND SO WE BASED OUR
COST ESTIMATES WANTING TO VERY
MUCH PROJECT OUT OUR BEST GUESS
BASED ON SUPER BOWL 50, BASED ON
OTHER EVENTS THAT WE HAVE. BUT
AS MORE THINGS COME INTO VIEW
OVER THE NEXT 12 TO 18 MONTHS,
IT REALLY WILL WILL HONE IN ON
THOSE COST ESTIMATES. AND THE
BAY AREA HOST COMMITTEE HAS
ENTERED INTO WHAT WE CALLED A
INTERIM FUNDING AGREEMENT TO
FUND OUR PLANNING COSTS AT THIS
TIME. AND SO WE ARE BUILDING
THEM FOR THOSE COSTS. ALL RIGHT.
I DO APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION. THANK YOU.
SORRY, SENATOR BRADFORD HAS A
QUESTION. YES. ONE ISSUE THAT
CONSTANTLY COME UP WHEN YOU HAVE
MAJOR EVENTS LIKE THIS IS THE
UTILIZATION AND INTERACTION WITH
LOCAL AND MINORITY, MINORITY
OWNED BUSINESSES. IS THERE ANY
TYPE OF PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE LOCAL BUSINESSES IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES BENEFIT
DIRECTLY, OTHER THAN THE
RESIDUAL EFFECTS THAT MIGHT
HAPPEN, BUT SOME DIRECT
COLLABORATION WITH THOSE? I'VE
HEARD IT FROM A LOT OF MY LOCAL
CHAMBERS AND ESPECIALLY A LOT OF
THE MINORITY BUSINESSES THAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO BE AT THE
TABLE TO BE ENGAGED IN A REAL
WAY. ABSOLUTELY. SENATOR, THAT'S
A GREAT QUESTION AND SPECIFIC
FOR THESE 2026 MAJOR EVENTS, THE
BAY AREA HOST COMMITTEE HAS
ACTUALLY PRIMED TO ANSWER THAT
THEY ARE PARTNERING. I KNOW BOTH
WITH THE NFL AND FIFA FOR A
PROGRAM TO BENEFIT BUSINESSES.
YES, IN SANTA CLARA, BUT ALSO
ACROSS THE REGION WITH A
PARTICULAR FOCUS ON SMALL LOCAL
WOMEN AND DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESSES. AND SO THEY'RE
WORKING ON A VERY ROBUST PROGRAM
AND WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT IT.
OKAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO DOUG ARNOTT,
SENIOR ADVISOR FOR OPERATIONS LÀ
SPORTS AND ENTERTAINMENT
COMMISSION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
SENATOR. SENATOR BRADLEY
BRADFORD, GOOD TO SEE YOU. JUST
A LITTLE BIT OF MY OWN HISTORY.
I WAS THE MANAGING THE EXECUTIVE
VICE PRESIDENT FOR OPERATIONS
FOR THE 94 WORLD CUP, A SIMILAR
ROLE FOR THE 96 OLYMPICS,
SIMILAR ROLE FOR THE 22,000
OLYMPICS IN SYDNEY. SIMILAR ROLE
FOR THE 2000 2002 OLYMPICS IN
SALT LAKE CITY. I'VE ALSO BEEN
ON THE SENIOR MANAGEMENT TEAMS
FOR THE LONDON OLYMPICS, WHERE I
WAS THE MANAGING DIRECTOR AND
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT FOR ALL
OPERATIONS, ALSO DID SIMILAR
ROLES FOR SOCHI AND THE RIO
OLYMPICS, AND I'M CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH THE LOS ANGELES
SPORTS AND ENTERTAINMENT
COMMISSION FOR THE 26TH WORLD
CUP. AND A SENIOR ADVISOR TO THE
LOS ANGELES 2028 OLYMPIC GAMES.
ALL OF THAT IS JUST TO HELP ME
TO UNDERSCORE WHAT A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY THESE GAMES WILL BE
FOR THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, BUT WITH HUGE
OPPORTUNITIES, OF COURSE, COME
HUGE RESPONSIBILITIES. AND IT'S
EVIDENT THAT YOU UNDERSTAND
THOSE RESPONSIBILITIES,
PARTICULARLY AS THEY RELATE TO
PUBLIC SAFETY. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR HELP, YOUR
SUPPORT, TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN HAVE A FANTASTIC TOURNAMENT,
BUT ALSO A VERY SAFE TOURNAMENT.
YOU HAD ASKED EARLIER WHAT THE
DIFFERENCE IS BETWEEN THE 94
WORLD CUP AND THIS WORLD CUP.
THIS WORLD CUP WILL BE TWICE THE
SIZE OF THE 94 WORLD CUP, TWO
TIMES AS MANY GAMES, MANY MORE
CITIES, THE FAN BASE
SIGNIFICANTLY GREATER. IT WILL
ALSO BE A MUCH MORE EXPANSIVE
TOURNAMENT WITH REGARD TO THOSE
ACTIVITIES THAT HAPPEN OFF SITE,
AWAY FROM THE STADIUMS, MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY
REFERENCED FANFEST AND WATCH
PARTIES, AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A
BROADER COMMUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE TOURNAMENT
AND ENJOY WHAT IS THE WORLD'S
MOST WATCHED EVENT. YOU'VE ALSO
HEARD FROM SOME OF OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY COLLEAGUES. THIS IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT. IT NEEDS
TO BE A COLLABORATIVE EFFORT. WE
ARE JUST NOW BEGINNING TO
FORMULATE MUCH MORE SIGNIFICANT
SUBCOMMITTEES TO BE ABLE TO
DEVELOP PLANS. AND SOME OF THE
AREAS THAT YOU'VE ADDRESSED,
INCLUDING COMMUNITY RELATIONS,
HUMAN TRAFFICKING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
THROUGH THE PROCUREMENT
PROGRAMS. SO A GREAT MANY OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU'VE ALREADY
RAISED ARE QUESTIONS THAT WE ASK
ON A REGULAR BASIS FOR EVENTS OF
THIS SORT. AND I THINK IN
GENERAL, WHAT I'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO TELL YOU IS THAT IT IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT. WE'VE
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH CHIEF
ARATA AND HIS TEAM, ALSO WITH
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL, LAPD,
LA SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT, AND AS
HAS ALSO BEEN STATED, EVEN IN IN
INGLEWOOD, IT'S A SIGNIFICANT
MUTUAL AID PROGRAM THAT WE PULL
TOGETHER FOR EVERY EVENT THAT WE
HAVE THERE. SO WE THINK THAT
WE'RE WE'RE ON PACE. THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE. THE LAST
18 MONTHS OF THESE EVENTS BECOME
ARE ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL, AND I'M
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I
MIGHT FOR YOU. THANK YOU. I DO
WANT TO UNDERSTAND, FOR EXAMPLE,
WHAT ARE THE PLANS IN PLACE TO
ENSURE PROPER COMMUNICATION
REGARDING SAFETY INFORMATION AND
UPDATES TO THE COMMUNITY'S
RESIDENTS, ESPECIALLY DURING ANY
POSSIBLE RESTRICTIONS DURING
THESE EVENTS? SO EACH OF THE
EACH OF THE GROUPS, EACH EACH
CITY WILL HAVE A COMMUNITY
RELATIONS DEPARTMENT. THE
COMMUNITY RELATIONS WILL WORK
CLOSELY WITH PUBLIC SAFETY. WE
WILL DEVELOP A COMMAND AND
CONTROL STRUCTURE THAT ALLOWS US
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE REAL
TIME INFORMATION, BUT ALSO
INFORMATION OUT IN ADVANCE, SO
THAT PEOPLE KNOW WHAT OUR
TRAFFIC RESTRICTIONS, WHAT'S
GOING TO BE HAPPENING, WHAT HOW
IS HOW ARE THE GAMES THEMSELVES
GOING TO GOING TO IMPACT THE
LIVES OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
THE VICINITY OF THE OF THE EVENT
AND ALSO MIGHT BE AFFECTED,
PARTICULARLY BY BY TRAFFIC AND
OTHER EVENTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
GAMES, WHICH MAY NOT BE PLANNED
BY THE BY THE ORGANIZING
COMMITTEES. OKAY. AND THEN FROM
A PUBLIC SAFETY PERSPECTIVE,
WITH TOURISTS AND
TRANSPORTATION, WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT IT THROUGH MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT CITIES. WHAT ARE YOU
GUYS PLANNING TO DO IN SUPPORT
OF THE HOMELESS POPULATION
AROUND THESE VENUES AND THESE
GAMES? THERE'S AGAIN, IT'S A
COMMUNITY RELATIONS PROGRAM
WHERE WE WORK WITH THE WORK WITH
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY. IN THE CASE
OF INGLEWOOD, IN THE CASE OF LOS
ANGELES, WE ARE WORKING WITH,
WE'LL BE WORKING TOGETHER TO
DEVELOP PLANS FOR THE HOMELESS
POPULATION AND ALSO FOR JUST THE
RESIDENTS AROUND THE FACILITIES
THEMSELVES TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR LIVES AREN'T INTERRUPTED.
AND WE HAVE IF WE IF, IF WE IF
THE PLANS OF THE GAMES AREN'T
WELL COMMUNICATED TO THE
HOMELESS COMMUNITY, IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR US TO PLAN WITH
THEM. SO THIS IS WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
HOMELESS COMMUNITY FOR THEM TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS SO
WE CAN PLAN WITH THEM, NOT FOR
THEM. OKAY, SO WHAT ARE KIND OF
THE LARGER EFFORTS AND GOALS OF
THIS PLAN WITH THE HOMELESS
POPULATION? SENATOR, I'LL BE
VERY HONEST WITH YOU. WE'RE 18
MONTHS OUT. I THINK THE
SPECIFICS OF THOSE PLANS WILL BE
DEVELOPED AS WE GO FORWARD. BUT
AT THIS POINT, HAVING IT ON OUR
RADAR SCREEN AND BEGINNING TO
WORK WITH THE SPECIFIC
COMMUNITIES WE DO NOT YET HAVE
FANFEST LOCATIONS YET FOR THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES. WE DON'T
HAVE THE WATCH PARTIES. IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR US TO SAY WHICH
COMMUNITIES ARE GOING TO BE
IMPACTED AS WE BEGIN TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO
DEVELOP THOSE PLANS MORE
BROADLY. THE SENATOR UNDERSTANDS
VERY WELL WHAT'S DONE ON A
REGULAR BASIS AROUND AROUND SOFI
STADIUM, AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH CHIEF ARATA AND HIS
TEAM ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF
SPECIFIC PLANS FOR THE
POPULATION AROUND THERE. CAN YOU
SHARE WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW? SO, FOR EXAMPLE, THE NBA
ALL STAR GAMES IS ONLY MONTHS
AWAY. SO I'D LIKE TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT IS THE CURRENT PROTOCOL IF
WE DON'T HAVE THE PLANS IN PLACE
FOR MONTHS AWAY, WHICH ALL STAR
GAME ANY ANY OF THE GAMES THAT
YOU GUYS HAVE RIGHT NOW, FOR
EXAMPLE? WELL, WE DON'T HAVE
THAT. SO LOS ANGELES DOESN'T
HAVE AN ALL STAR GAME FOR SOME
TIME. SO I HAVEN'T WE HAVEN'T
STARTED ANY WORK ON THOSE.
HOWEVER THE AREA AROUND THE AREA
AROUND THE NEW CLIPPERS STADIUM,
WHICH IS WHERE THE NBA ALL STAR
GAME WILL BE WHEN IT COMES TO
LOS ANGELES, IS NOT AN AREA THAT
HAS A SIGNIFICANT HOMELESS
POPULATION. IT'S MUCH MORE OF AN
INDUSTRIAL OF A COMMERCIAL AREA
THAN IT IS A THAN THAN AN AREA
FOR HOMELESS POPULATION. I CAN
RELY ON THE CHIEF, PLEASE. I CAN
ADD SOME COMMENT THERE. YEAH.
GREAT QUESTION IN INGLEWOOD AND
I'M SURE THE SENATOR IS AWARE OF
THIS. WE HAVE AN EXTENSIVE
HOMELESS OUTREACH PROGRAM. I
HAVE A DMA PERSON EMBEDDED WITH
US FROM L.A. COUNTY, ONE OF THE
FIRST ONES IN THE COUNTY TO
FORMULATE THAT TEAM. SO WE HAVE
HOUSING, WORK WITH GROUPS FOR
HOUSING. AND, YOU KNOW, WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH OUR HOMELESS
POPULATION. IT'S A DIFFICULT
TASK AS YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES THEY
DON'T ACCEPT SOME OF THESE
OFFERINGS, BUT WE WORK HARD TO
FIND PLACEMENT FOR THEM. AND
HAVING THE DMA PERSON EMBEDDED
WITH A WHOLE TEAM THAT I HAVE,
AND I'M SURE A LOT OF THE
MUNICIPALITIES HAVE THAT AS WELL.
IT'S A IT'S A GREAT WAY TO AT
LEAST EXTEND OUR SERVICES TO
THESE FOLKS AND PROVIDE THE HELP
THAT THEY NEED. SO, OKAY, SO,
FOR EXAMPLE, THE CITY OF SANTA
CLARA SAID THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO HAVE SAFE RV PARKING SITES
AND THINGS LIKE THAT. AND
OBVIOUSLY HOMELESS NAVIGATION
CENTER IS THROUGHOUT THE BAY
AREA. AND I'M SURE THAT LA ALSO
HAS IT. WHAT HAPPENS IF THEY DO
NOT ACCEPT YOUR SERVICES? WELL,
WE UNFORTUNATELY WE CAN'T FORCE
THEM, BUT WE CONTINUOUSLY TRY
AND OFFER THEM VOUCHERS FOR
FOOD, HOUSING, THINGS OF THAT
NATURE AND I HAVE A GREAT TEAM
AND I KNOW OTHER MUNICIPALITIES
DO AS WELL. SO WE YOU KNOW,
STRIKE A CHORD WITH THESE FOLKS.
AND I THINK THE SENATOR IS
FAMILIAR WITH MISS CINDERELLA.
SHE'S AN AMAZING PERSON WHO HAS
GOTTEN PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN ON
THE STREETS FOR A DECADE,
VETERANS AND GOT THEM TO BE
REUNITED WITH FAMILY MEMBERS OR
INTO SOME SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND
SO FORTH. SO WE DON'T GIVE UP
EASY. OKAY, I APPRECIATE IT. MY
CONCERN, AND I THINK THAT THIS
IS GOING TO BE A POINT OF
CONCERN MOVING FORWARD IS HOW WE
DEAL WITH THE HOMELESS
POPULATION IN A RESPECTFUL AND
DIGNIFIED APPROACH. OBVIOUSLY,
WE WANT PEOPLE HOUSED AND WE
ALSO KNOW THAT SOME PEOPLE HAVE
PROBLEMS THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO
BE HOUSED OR THEY REFUSE
SERVICES, OR THEY HAVE A MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITION OR WHATEVER THE
CASE MAY BE. I JUST WANT TO
ENSURE FOR ALL THE PANELISTS
HERE THAT WE DO NOT JUST DRIVE
OUT OR MOVE HOMELESS PEOPLE FROM
ONE PLACE TO ANOTHER. NUMBER ONE
AND NUMBER TWO, WHEN ENGAGING
WITH THEM, WE ARE STILL
RESPECTFUL THAT THEY ARE HUMAN
BEINGS AND SO FORTH. EVEN IF
THEY MAKE PEOPLE UNCOMFORTABLE
OR IT'S SEEN AS UNSIGHTLY FOR
OTHERS AND SO FORTH. SO I LEAVE
THAT. I'M HOPING THAT THERE IS
MORE OF A PLAN THERE, ESPECIALLY
CONSIDERING THAT LA DOES HAVE
FAR MORE ACTIVITY THAN I WILL
SAY, EVEN IN THE BAY AREA. IN
REGARDS TO ENTERTAINMENT. AND
THEN AT THE SAME TIME, I DO ALSO
WANT TO PRIORITIZE THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING PIECE. THAT IS A BIG
CONCERN. WE ALREADY SEE IT IN
THE UNITED STATES WITH OTHER
LARGE GAMES AND EVENTS. SO
AGAIN, HOPEFULLY THAT THE ENTIRE
STATE CAN PRIORITIZE THIS AND
WORK ON THIS BECAUSE I DO NOT
WANT TO SEE IT IN THE NEWS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I WOULD I
WOULD JUST PIGGYBACK ON THAT AS
WELL AND RECOGNIZE THAT AS THE
CHIEF STATED, MUCH OF THE
HOMELESS POPULATION IS OUTSIDE
THE CITY OF INGLEWOOD. SO I WANT
TO COMMEND THE MAYOR, MAYOR
BASS, FOR HER AGGRESSIVE
PROGRAM. THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THIS. BUT SHE'S ALREADY
HAVING A GREAT IMPACT ON GETTING
PEOPLE HOUSED. AND I KNOW HER
COMMITMENT IS GOING TO EVEN
EXPAND THAT AS THESE GAMES COME
CLOSER TO FRUITION HERE AND
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. BUT SHE
HAS MADE IT A PRIORITY TO GET
PEOPLE HOUSED SAFELY AND
RESPECTFULLY AND IN A VERY
HUMANE WAY. SO I KNOW SHE'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL THE
PARTIES INVOLVED IN THIS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I AGREE, I
CONCUR, SENATOR, WE WILL START
WITH PANEL THREE. STATE AGENCY
REPRESENTATIVES. WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE DONALD O'KEEFE, CHIEF LAW
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION, CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES, FOLLOWED BY RODNEY
ELLISON, ASSISTANT COMMISSIONER,
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. EXCUSE ME.
GOOD MORNING. CHAIR WAHAB.
SENATOR BRADFORD. MY NAME IS DON
O'KEEFE, AND I AM THE CHIEF OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES. I ALSO AM THE
STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT MUTUAL
AID COORDINATOR ON A STATEWIDE
BASIS, EVERY DISASTER EMERGENCY
STARTS AND ENDS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. CAL OES LAW ENFORCEMENT
BRANCH COORDINATES LOCAL, STATE,
AND FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
STAKEHOLDERS IN RESPONSE TO
INCIDENTS AND NEEDS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
BEYOND TO PROTECT LIVES AND
PROPERTY, BUILD CAPACITY,
SUPPORT COMMUNITIES, AND FOR
RESILIENT CALIFORNIA. WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH ALL 58 CALIFORNIA
SHERIFFS, 334 CITY POLICE CHIEFS
AND OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONALS. THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT BRANCH PROVIDES
GUIDANCE, PERSONNEL, CRITICAL
RESOURCES FOR AGENCIES TO
SUCCESSFULLY AND EFFICIENTLY
MANAGE EVENTS OCCURRING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND IN SOME
CASES, AT THE SAME TIME. TO THAT
END, CAL OES AND HOMELAND
SECURITY DIVISION HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH MULTIPLE PARTNERS
JURISDICTIONS IN PREPARATION FOR
THE UPCOMING LARGE SCALE EVENTS
TO INCLUDE, LIKE YOU'VE HEARD,
2025 WORLD CLUB CUP, THE 2026
FIFA WORLD CUP, 2026 SUPER BOWL,
60, 2027 SUPER BOWL, 61 AND THE
2028 OLYMPIC AND PARALYMPIC
GAMES. CAL WEST HAS BEEN ENGAGED
IN WIDE RANGING DISCUSSIONS
RELATED TO THE FORMATION OF A
REGIONAL PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
AND MULTIPLE COORDINATION
EFFORTS CHAIRED BY THE HOST
JURISDICTIONS. THE NATIONAL
SECURITY SPECIAL EVENT, ALSO
KNOWN AS AN NSC, IS A DESIGNATED
EVENT THAT, DUE TO ITS POLITICAL,
ECONOMIC, SOCIAL OR RELIGIOUS
SIGNIFICANCE, MAY BE A TARGET
FOR DOMESTIC OR INTERNATIONAL
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY DUE TO ITS
NATIONAL SIGNIFICANCE AND HIGH
VISIBILITY. THE UNITED SECRET
SERVICE IS THE LEAD FEDERAL
AGENCY. A SPECIAL EVENT
ASSESSMENT RATING, ALSO KNOWN AS
A SERE, IS A, IS A RISK BASED
EVALUATION PROCESS SERVING AS A
STARTING POINT. FOR INTERAGENCY
SPECIAL EVENTS, WORKING GROUP,
BY PROVIDING AN INITIAL
NUMERICAL RISK SCORE FOR ALL
EVENTS SUBMITTED RECENTLY, BOTH
THE OLYMPIC AND PARALYMPIC GAMES
WERE DESIGNATED AS NATIONAL
SECURITY EVENT. SPECIAL SECURITY
EVENT. THE 2025 WORLD CLUB CUP,
AND THE 2026 WORLD CUP WILL HAVE
A TIER TWO RATING, WITH THE
FINAL MATCHES BEING A TIER ONE
RATING. WE ARE AND WILL REMAIN
ENGAGED THROUGH THE PLANNING,
RESPONSE AND RELEVANT POST EVENT
NEEDS. SEVERAL MEETINGS HAVE
ALREADY OCCURRED FOR THE 2028
OLYMPICS, AND CAL OES HAD ITS
FIRST MEETING WITH THE SANTA
CLARA POLICE DEPARTMENT
REGARDING RESOURCE NEEDS FOR THE
2026 WORLD CUP AND SUPER BOWL
60. TO THAT END, THERE ARE BEST
PRACTICES THAT, WHEN PUT IN
PLACE, CAN SET COMMUNITIES UP
FOR SUCCESSFUL EVENTS THAT ARE
SAFE, SEAMLESS AND
IMPLEMENTATION WHILE MAINTAINING
A FESTIVE AND UNINTERRUPTED
EXPERIENCE FOR ALL. AS THE 2024
SUMMER OLYMPIC GAMES IN PARIS
APPROACH, CAL, CAL OS SEES A
VALUABLE OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE
WITH A DELEGATION FROM THE
FRENCH GOVERNMENT IN FEBRUARY OF
THIS PAST YEAR, SOME OF THE KEY
TAKEAWAYS ENSURING A ROBUST,
UNINTERRUPTED COMMUNICATION PLAN
FOR INTELLIGENCE SHARING LEADING
UP TO, DURING AND AFTER EACH
EVENT. DISCUSSIONS FOCUSED ON
SHARING OF THREAT INTELLIGENCE,
PARTICULARLY CONCERNING AI,
CYBERSECURITY, SECURITY MEASURES
AND SAFEGUARDING CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE, WHILE
EMPHASIZING A PROACTIVE APPROACH
TOWARDS LARGE SCALE EVENTS LIKE
WE'RE GOING TO SEE WITH THE
WORLD CUP, SUPER BOWL AND
OLYMPICS SET UP, SECURITY
MEASURES THAT OTHERS HAVE USED
AND HAVE WORKED FOR THEIR
COMMUNITY. RECOGNIZING THAT
SECURITY MEASURES MAY LOOK VERY
DIFFERENT ACROSS DIFFERENT
CITIES AND COUNTIES WITH
DIFFERENT NEEDS, START PREPARING
NOW. COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE MUTUAL
AID AGREEMENTS SHOULD REVIEW AND
UPDATE IT ACCORDINGLY. IF THEY
ARE LACKING ANY AGREEMENTS WITH
RELEVANT DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES THAT, AT THE LOCAL AND
REGIONAL LEVEL LEVEL, THOSE
DISCUSSIONS SHOULD BEGIN NOW.
FOR LARGE SCALE STADIUM AND
CROWD EVENTS THAT CAL OES. WE
BEGIN PREPARATIONS. IF NOT YEARS
IN ADVANCE. THE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I'M SORRY WE BEGIN MONTHS, IF
NOT YEARS IN ADVANCE. THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
BRINGS STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER AND
LEVERAGES ONGOING PARTNERSHIPS
WITH CITY, COUNTY, STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
THAT AT CAL OES, WE USE AN ALL
HAZARDS APPROACH IN PLANNING THE
POTENTIAL FOR CONCURRENT
EMERGENCIES AND THEIR CASCADING
IMPACTS NEEDS TO BE CAREFULLY
CONSIDERED AND PLANNED FOR. THIS
INCLUDES EVENTS LIKE EARTHQUAKES,
FLOODS, FIRES, AND ACTIVE
SHOOTERS. A CASE IN POINT ON
OCTOBER 17TH, 1989, A 9.6
EARTHQUAKE HIT THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA AND BEYOND, WHILE GAME
NUMBER THREE OF THE WORLD SERIES
BETWEEN THE SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS
AND THE OAKLAND ATHLETICS WAS
BEING PLAYED AT CANDLESTICK PARK.
CAL OES ROLE IN PREPARING OR
PRE-PLANNING ASSISTANCE TO THE
AGENCY. PRIMARY LAW ENFORCEMENT
JURISDICTION OVER THE EVENT.
SPECIFICALLY, MY STAFF WILL HELP
TO WRITE INCIDENT ACTION PLANS,
ENSURE THE AGENCY IS AWARE OF
THE STANDARD EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM, OR SIMS,
COORDINATING MUTUAL AID BEING
REQUESTED. WORKING WITH THE
STATE THREAT ASSESSMENT CENTER
AND REGIONAL FUSION CENTERS TO
GAIN INTELLIGENCE ON THE EVENT.
PARTICIPATING IN TABLETOP
EXERCISES, IDENTIFYING LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES, RESOURCES
THAT CAN BE USED IN THE EVENT OF
AN EMERGENCY OR DISASTER, AND
PLANNING FOR THE USE OF STATE
RESOURCES. IF LOCAL AND REGIONAL
RESOURCES HAVE BEEN EXHAUSTED.
WHEN CAL WEST AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT BRANCH IS ON SITE
DURING THE EVENT, WE RELAY
CRITICAL INFORMATION AND
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS TO CAL OES
LEADERSHIP AND THE GOVERNOR AND
KEY STAFF PROVIDE ON SCENE
COORDINATION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT,
MUTUAL AID IN THE EVENT OF A
DISASTER OR EMERGENCY, AND
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WITH AFTER ACTION REPORTS. IN
ADDITION TO THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
BRANCH, THE CAL U.S. HOMELAND
SECURITY DIVISION, WHICH IS
COMPRISED OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE THREAT ASSESSMENT CENTER,
ALSO KNOWN AS THE STACK, AND THE
CALIFORNIA CYBER SECURITY
INTEGRATION CENTER, ALSO KNOWN
AS CALCIC, WILL PROVIDE VARIOUS
LEVELS OF SUPPORT THROUGH THE
ENTIRETY OF THE LARGE SCALE
EVENT. THE STAFF WILL ASSIST IN
THE INFORMATION SHARING
ENVIRONMENT AS WELL AS VARIOUS
WORKING GROUPS IN PREPARATION
FOR THE UPCOMING EVENT. THE
STACK WILL ALSO PROVIDE REAL
TIME OPEN SOURCE INTELLIGENCE
RESEARCH AND ANALYSIS ANALYSIS
TO IDENTIFY EMERGENCY THREATS
DURING THE EVENT. ADDITIONALLY,
THE STACKS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROTECTION UNIT
WILL ASSIST FEDERAL, STATE, AND
LOCAL PARTNERS DURING A THREAT
VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENT IN
PREPARATION FOR THE EVENTS, THE
CAL SIC WILL PROVIDE THE
FOLLOWING ASSISTS IN THE SHARING
OF CYBER RELATED INFORMATION AND
PARTICIPATE IN CYBER WORKING
GROUPS IN THE LEAD UP TO THE
EVENTS, WE ALSO IDENTIFY. WE
ALSO IDENTIFY AND ASSIGN CYBER
ANALYSTS TO PROVIDE REAL TIME
CYBER SUPPORT DURING THE
OPERATIONAL PERIOD TO ENSURE
RESILIENCY OF THE CYBER
INFRASTRUCTURE. IN SUMMARY, CAL
OES WILL BE WILL CONTINUE TO BE
ACTIVELY ENGAGED WITH ALL
PARTNER AGENCIES AHEAD OF THE
EVENTS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
STATED, AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE ONGOING COMMUNICATION AND
COLLABORATION AND COORDINATION
THAT WILL BE NECESSARY TO ENSURE
THESE EVENTS ARE SAFE AND
SECURE. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY, AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. I DO
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS. DO
YOU HAVE ANY? SENATOR BRADFORD
WILL START FIRST MINDS REAL
QUICK. YOU BRIEFLY TOUCHED ON
NATURAL DISASTERS AND YOU SPOKE
TO EARTHQUAKES. ARE THERE ANY
PROTOCOLS OR PREPAREDNESS FOR
WILDFIRES? UNFORTUNATELY, THAT'S
BEEN MORE OF AN OCCURRENCE
THING. SO IF THERE ARE ANY
POTENTIAL PLANS FOR THAT, WELL,
WE WOULD ALSO JUST I MEAN MINE
IS LAW ENFORCEMENT BRANCH BUT A
CAL OES WE HAVE OUR FIRE RESCUE
BRANCH. WE HAVE OUR RECOVERY
SECTION. WE ALSO HAVE OUR
EMERGENCY SERVICES COORDINATORS
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO HELP
COORDINATE. IF WE DID HAVE A
FIRE THAT WOULD, WITH THE LOCAL
RESOURCES COORDINATING, GETTING
THEM FIRE LAW OR WHATEVER THAT
IS NECESSARY. SO WE WOULD HAVE
THOSE FOLKS AVAILABLE AS WELL.
THANK YOU. SO YOU TALKED A LOT
ABOUT MUTUAL AID. I WANT TO
UNDERSTAND YOUR EFFORT AROUND
PLANNED AID. I'M SORRY, PLANNED
AID. PLANNED AID. RIGHT. SO THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM IS BASED REALLY FOR
DISASTERS AND EMERGENCIES, THE
MASTER MUTUAL AID AGREEMENT THAT
WE HAVE WHEN IT'S A PLANNED
EVENT, THEN THAT IS UP TO THE
AGENCIES TO LEVERAGE MOU WITH
DIFFERENT AGENCIES. I THINK THE
CHIEFS HAVE TALKED ABOUT OR THE
CITY MANAGER IN SANTA CLARA, HOW
THEY'RE GOING OUT STATEWIDE.
THOSE WILL BE THROUGH MOU TO
BRING THOSE LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESOURCES IN, IN, YOU KNOW, IN
TALKING TO SANTA CLARA, I THINK,
YOU KNOW, IN THE LOS ANGELES
AREA, THERE'S A LOT OF RESOURCES
IN THE BAY AREA. IT'S A LITTLE
DIFFERENT. NOT AS BIG AS CITIES,
BUT THEY ARE PROACTIVELY LOOKING
TO GET THOSE ADDITIONAL OFFICERS
IN PLACE SO THAT THEY HAVE THE
NECESSARY BOTH PRIVATE SECURITY
AS WELL AS LAW ENFORCEMENT,
WHERE WE WOULD COME IN IF THERE
WAS SOMETHING ABOVE AND BEYOND A
DISASTER OR GOD FORBID, AN
EARTHQUAKE, THEN WE WOULD
LEVERAGE THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
AND BRING THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IN THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. OKAY. AND I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE YOU GUYS ARE
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES. SO I UNDERSTAND THAT.
MY CONCERN HERE, THOUGH, IS WITH
THE AMOUNT OF VACANCIES IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACROSS THE BOARD,
RIGHT? EVERY SINGLE CITY HAS
ROUGHLY 20, 25% PLUS VACANT
UNITS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONALS. PLANNED AID SEEMS
A LITTLE HARD, RIGHT NOW, AND I
JUST WANT TO UNDERSTAND, IS
THERE ANY EFFORT FROM CAL OES TO
OFFER SOME TYPE OF MUTUAL AID
FOR FIFA WORLD CUP IN
CALIFORNIA, JUST BECAUSE OF THE
MAGNITUDE OF INTEREST IN THIS
PARTICULAR GAME? WELL, THE
MUTUAL AID WOULD HAVE TO COME
FROM THE CITIES AND THE COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WE CANNOT
FORCE THEM TO PROVIDE THOSE
RESOURCES. I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
SOME POSSIBLE FINANCIAL FUNDS
AVAILABLE THAT MAY BE ABLE TO
ASSIST WITH THAT. I WILL SAY ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I DID THIS
DURING THE CIVIL UNREST EARLIER
THIS IN THE SPRING, YOU KNOW,
IT'S NOT UNCOMMON FOR ME TO MAKE
PHONE CALLS TO CHIEFS AND
SHERIFFS AND SAY, LISTEN, WE
REALLY NEED YOUR HELP. THOSE
WERE BASICALLY WERE PRE-PLANNED
EVENTS. SO BUT THEY'RE NOT
OBLIGATED TO SEND ANY PERSONNEL.
OKAY. WITH THAT SAID, I ALSO
WANT TO UNDERSTAND, YOU KNOW,
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE SAFEGUARDS.
AGAIN, I KNOW THAT YOU GUYS HAVE
THE CYBER SECURITY UNIT HOUSED
IN OES TO PROTECT PEOPLE'S
PERSONAL DATA FROM MISUSE OR
SURVEILLANCE DURING THESE MAJOR
GAMES, RIGHT. AND THAT'S
ACTUALLY A DIFFERENT DIVISION
FROM WHERE I WORK. BUT I DO KNOW
THAT THE FIRST AMENDMENT
CONSIDERATIONS ARE ALWAYS TAKEN
INTO CONSIDERATION. THOSE ARE
BUILT INTO OUR POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES. SO THAT IS
CONSTANTLY BEING EVALUATED. AND
TO ENSURE WE DON'T HAVE THOSE
ISSUES. ALL RIGHT. WELL I
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE RODNEY
ELLISON, ASSISTANT COMMISSIONER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL. I DON'T KNOW IF THIS
WILL RISE UP. OKAY. GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M
ASSISTANT COMMISSIONER RODNEY
ELLISON, AND I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF COMMISSIONER SHONDRAE,
WHO EXTENDS HIS APPRECIATION FOR
ALLOWING US TO COME HERE AND
SHARE WITH YOU THIS MORNING. I
WANT TO TOUCH ON FOUR ITEMS I
THINK WOULD HELP KIND OF EXPLAIN
OUR POSTURE FOR THESE EVENTS
THAT ARE COMING TO OUR GREAT
STATE. THE FIRST ONE IS HOW IS
THE CHP APPROACHED EVENTS? IN
THE PAST, THE CHP HAS PLAYED A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN CALIFORNIA'S
PAST. MAJOR EVENTS, INCLUDING
THE 1984 OLYMPICS, WHICH WERE
ALSO HOSTED IN LOS ANGELES. AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE, COMMUNICATION
AND PLANNING AND COLLABORATION
ARE ESSENTIAL FOR OUR SUCCESS.
WE WELCOME ENGAGEMENT FROM THE
HOST COMMITTEES FROM BOTH LOS
ANGELES AND THE BAY AREA, AS WE
RELY HEAVILY ON THESE EVENT
ACTION PLANS FOR OUR SUCCESS.
EACH EVENT HAS AN EVENT ACTION
PLAN THAT'S DEVELOPED AND
PROVIDED TO ALL PERSONNEL
INVOLVED IN THE EVENT. THE EVENT
ACTION PLAN ALSO PROVIDES A
MISSION STATEMENT AND OUTLINES
THE ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES
OF THE HOST COMMITTEE AND THE
LOCAL, STATE AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES INVOLVED IN
CONTRIBUTING TO A SAFE AND
SECURE EVENT FOR THOSE ATTENDING
THE COMMUNITIES AND THE
COMMUNITIES HOSTING THE EVENT.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN JUNE OF 2022,
THE DEPARTMENT WORKED CLOSELY
WITH THE UNITED STATES SECRET
SERVICE, UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF STATE, AND LAPD
FOR THE NINTH SUMMIT OF
AMERICAS, WHICH WAS A HIGH
PROFILE EVENT INVOLVING 55
DIGNITARIES AND HEADS OF STATES
FROM 35 DIFFERENT COUNTRIES. THE
EVENT UTILIZED MULTIPLE VENUES
WHERE COMMUNICATION AND
COORDINATION OF PERSONNEL,
TRAVEL ROUTES, PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION, ESCORTS WERE.
THIS WAS ESSENTIAL TO THE
SUCCESS OF THE OF THE EVENT, THE
OLYMPICS AND THE WORLD CUP GAMES
WILL HAVE SIMILAR EVENTS WHICH
WILL TAKE PLACE AT DIFFERENT
VENUES, REQUIRING COMMUNICATION
AMONGST ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENSURE WE PROVIDE THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF SAFETY AND SERVICE FOR
THE EVENT. THE SECOND THING I
WANT TO TOUCH ON IS HOW THE CSP,
WORKING WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN THE PAST
TO ENSURE SECURITY. WHILE THE
CHP HAS ALWAYS WORKED CLOSELY
WITH LOCAL, STATE AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
ENOUGH EQUIPMENT, TRAINING AND
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO ENSURE
THAT EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO IS GOING TO BE SAFE AGAIN.
THAT'S WHY THESE EVENT ACTION
PLANS ARE KEY. AND THE RESULT OF
SEVERAL MEETINGS AND A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
COLLABORATION WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE INVOLVED.
THE THIRD THING I WANT TO TOUCH
ON IS TRANSPORTATION. THIS WILL
BE KEY FOR ALL THE EVENTS THAT
ARE THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE. MULTI-AGENCY COMMAND
CENTERS ARE UTILIZED TO
COORDINATE ALL ACTIVITIES OF
INVOLVED AGENCIES. THE CHP WORKS
WITH LOCAL AGENCIES, CALTRANS,
COUNTY ROADS AND LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES TO IDENTIFY AND
ESTABLISH FREEWAY CLOSURES,
DETAILS, DETOURS TO MITIGATE
TRAFFIC AND CONGESTION FOR THE
DURATION OF THE EVENTS. THE
FOURTH THING IS WHAT MEASURES
HAVE BEEN PUT INTO PLACE FOR
PREVIOUS EVENTS FOR POTENTIAL
INCIDENTS. WHILE THE CHP HAS A
SPECIAL RESPONSE TEAM THAT WE
DEPLOY, WE CAN DEPLOY AT A
MOMENT'S NOTICE. WE USE THIS
TEAM RECENTLY WITH THE APEC
CONFERENCE IN THE BAY AREA,
SUPER BOWLS, SUPER BOWLS IN
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA, AND THE COLLEGE
NATIONAL FOOTBALL CHAMPIONSHIP
GAME. AS NOTED EARLIER, WE ALSO
USE THE SAME TEAM FOR THE SUMMIT
OF AMERICAS TO GIVE YOU SOME
INSIGHT OF OUR SPECIAL RESPONSE
TEAM, WE AS I SAID, WE HAVE ONE
IN EACH OF OUR EIGHT FIELD
DIVISIONS AND THESE TEAMS
CONSIST OF ABOUT 80 MEMBERS ON
EACH TEAM. THEY'RE SPECIALLY
TRAINED TO RESPOND TO MITIGATE
CIVIL UNREST, AND TO ADDRESS ANY
EMERGENCY THAT THAT THAT MAY
ARISE. THIS TEAM HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN THROUGH MANY OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'VE HAD THEM
CALLED TO DO. RECENTLY. WE HAD
AN UPRISING AT THE UCLA CAMPUS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, WHERE WE
HAD THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THERE,
AND OUR TEAM DOWN THERE WAS ABLE
TO COME IN AND MITIGATE THAT.
THE INCIDENT THAT TOOK PLACE FOR
THE COPA AMERICA AT THE HARD
ROCK STADIUM IN MIAMI IS A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF HOW THIS TEAM COULD
BE UTILIZED. SO WE TAKE OUR
POSTURE FOR OUR TEAMS WILL BE
WE'LL BE READY FOR WHATEVER
COMES WITH THESE EVENTS THAT
COME TO CALIFORNIA. AND
COMMISSIONER DARIA RECOGNIZES
THAT THE FAN BASE IS FOR SOCCER,
BASEBALL, FOOTBALL, BASKETBALL
ARE ALL DIFFERENT. WE HAVE A LOT
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO BE
COMING TO CALIFORNIA TO ENGAGE
AND SHARE IN OUR OUR GREAT STATE
AS A RESULT, TO KIND OF GET SOME
INSIGHT TO THAT. WE'VE BEEN
SPEAKING WITH OUR INTERNATIONAL
PARTNERS AS WELL. AND
COMMISSIONER DARIA ACTUALLY SENT
SOMEONE TO THE PARIS OLYMPICS
OVER THE SUMMER TO GET INSIGHT
OF SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
THEY HAD SO WE COULD GET GOOD
INSIGHT TO HOW WE WOULD ADDRESS
ISSUES. AS FOR LÀ 28, I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT THE DEPARTMENT
IS PROACTIVELY SEEKING OUT
STRATEGIES THAT CAN BE UTILIZED
IN CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF SAFETY AND
SECURITY TO ALL THOSE WHO WILL
BE LIVING IN CALIFORNIA DURING
THE THESE MAJOR EVENTS, AND
VISITING OUR GREAT STATE. IN
CLOSING, I'D LIKE TO THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE THE EVENT. THESE
EVENTS IN CALIFORNIA WILL BE IN
PUBLIC VIEW FOR THE WORLD. AND
WE KNOW THAT HAVING SPECIFIC
ROLES AND FUNCTIONS THAT WE ALL
NEED TO BE ACCOMPLISHED FOR US
TO HAVE A SUCCESSFUL EVENT IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR, AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
FOR GIVING US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY. AND I'D
LIKE TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE FOR US. THANK YOU.
NUMBER ONE, I JUST KIND OF WANT
TO UNDERSTAND, YOU KNOW, THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN THIS PAST
YEAR DEPLOYED A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PUBLIC SAFETY EFFORTS IN THE BAY
AREA, LARGELY AROUND OAKLAND,
BUT THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA. ARE
WE ABLE TO SEE AN EFFORT LIKE
THAT FOR ROUGHLY THE MONTH? THAT
IS A TARGETED MONTH FROM JUNE TO
JULY AROUND THE WORLD CUP? YES.
WE'LL BE WE'LL BE ABLE TO
RESPOND IN A SIMILAR FASHION
WITH WITH RESOURCES THAT WILL
PROVIDE THE RIGHT LEVEL OF
COVERAGE. THAT'S WHERE THOSE
MEETINGS THAT WE HAVE, WE WORK
WITH OUR LOCAL PARTNERS ALL THE
TIME IN TALKING ABOUT THINGS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED, BUT
WE'LL BE OUR POSTURE IS THAT
WE'LL WE'LL HAVE THE SAME LEVEL
OF COVERAGE THAT WE HAVE NOW.
AND GRANTED, OUR FIRST PANEL
STATED THAT PUBLIC TRANSIT IS,
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
A LOT OF THE FANS ARE GOING TO
BE LOOKING FOR, BUT WE ALSO HAVE
A LOT OF UBER AND LYFT AND SO
FORTH. BUT WITH THAT, AGAIN,
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
HOMELESSNESS AND SO FORTH ARE
ALSO OF CONCERN. WHAT ARE YOUR
COMMENTS AROUND THAT? THOSE ARE
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES. AND WE'RE
ALWAYS LOOKING AT WAYS TO
IMPROVE OUR TRAINING AND FOCUS
ON THOSE ISSUES. THE
HOMELESSNESS ISSUE IS SOMETHING
THAT WE ENGAGE IN ROUTINELY NOW
WITH CALTRANS AND, AND, AND THE
RESOURCES AROUND THAT. SO WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
AND AS WE RAMP UP FOR THAT,
WE'LL BE ABLE TO ADDRESS ALL
THOSE THINGS. IN REGARDS TO
HUMAN TRAFFICKING, THERE ARE
SEVERAL TASK FORCES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WE'RE WORKING ON OUR
CURRENT TRAINING INTERNALLY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THAT AS WE CURRENTLY DO
NOW, WHEN WE COME ACROSS IT.
DEFINITELY. AND THEN YOU
REFERENCED UCLA AND I ALSO JUST
WANT TO REFERENCE THAT BECAUSE
THESE ARE GAMES. THIS IS
ENTERTAINMENT. I'M HOPING THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT ACROSS THE
BOARD, WHETHER IT'S LOCAL POLICE
OR CHP OR ANY OTHER AGENCY
INVOLVED, USE NONLETHAL EFFORTS
IF NEED BE. BUT FOR THE MOST
PART, NOBODY SHOULD DIE BECAUSE
OF A SPORTS GAME. ABSOLUTELY.
WITH WITH THAT, WHEN YOU WHEN WE
HAVE GAMES LIKE THIS AND WE
DEPLOY OUR SPECIAL RESPONSE
TEAM, YOU KNOW, WE COMMUNICATE
AND WE HAVE THAT VISIBLE
PRESENCE. AND I THINK IT'S BEEN
SHOWN WHEN WE ARE, WHEN WE SHOW
UP THAT WAY, WHEN WE HAVE A LOT
OF RESOURCES AVAILABLE AND
PRESENT, IT KIND OF THWARTS ANY,
ANY, ANY, ANYTHING THAT MAY
HAPPEN. AND THAT'S BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN THE PAST USING
THAT MODEL. SO WE'LL WE'LL MAKE
SURE WE HAVE OUR TEAMS DEPLOYED
AHEAD OF TIME. WE'LL HAVE GOOD
CONVERSATIONS, WILL BE GOOD
COMMUNICATION, AND WE'LL WORK
WITH ALL THE AGENCIES INVOLVED
TO HAVE THAT THAT VISIBLE
PRESENCE OUT THERE. AS I LONG WAY IN STOPPING
THINGS BEFORE THEY START.
DEFINITELY WITH, YOU KNOW, A LOT
OF THE CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD,
YOU KNOW, MANY PEOPLE HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED, YOU KNOW, LA AND
THE BAY AREA OR DEFINITELY
ECONOMIC HUBS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, BUT ALSO WITH THE
WORLD CUP BEING HERE AND ONE OF
THE MOST HIGHLY VIEWED, HIGHLY
PUBLICIZED GAMES IN THE WORLD,
PERIOD, THERE'S A LOT OF CONCERN
OF POTENTIAL PROTESTS. THERE'S A
LOT OF CONCERN REGARDING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, REGARDING
HOMELESSNESS, REGARDING A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT WOULD
REQUIRE LAW ENFORCEMENTS
ENGAGEMENT. AND SO MY CONCERN
AND I WANT TO PRIORITIZE THIS AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE, IS THAT THERE
WILL BE A LOT OF SCRUTINY IF
MISTAKES ARE MADE. AND OBVIOUSLY
MISTAKES ARE BOUND TO HAPPEN.
BUT I WANT TO JUST MAKE SURE AND
THE WHOLE REASON FOR HAVING THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING IS TO
PRIORITIZE MORE PLANNING AND
PREPARATION RATHER THAN A
RESPONSE TO SOMETHING. RIGHT?
AND GRANTED, WE CANNOT CONTROL
EVERY SINGLE ASPECT OF WHAT WILL
HAPPEN, BUT I WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT EVERY SINGLE ORGANIZATION
WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH EACH
OTHER. WE ALL HAVE ONE GOAL,
WHICH IS A SUCCESSFUL
ENTERTAINMENT PERIOD IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, AND
HOPEFULLY MORE TO COME. BUT WITH
THAT SAID, I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT MY FINAL COMMENTS
GENUINELY IS THAT EVERYONE
COLLABORATES IN GOOD FAITH WITH
EACH OTHER AND WE PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S INTERESTS. WE
PROTECT THE RESIDENTS, AND WE
MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER. YES,
THAT'S I APPRECIATE THAT. WE USE
INTEL QUITE A BIT. NOW. ALL THE
AGENCIES THAT ARE HERE TODAY,
AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE A PART
OF THIS USES INTEL. SO THE INTEL
WILL GIVE US A LOT OF INSIGHT OF
WHO MAY SHOW UP AND USUALLY WITH
THAT THERE'S AN EVENT ORGANIZER
OR SOMEONE WE CAN TALK TO GET AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THEIR
CONCERNS ARE, WHY THEY'RE GOING
TO BE THERE, THE NUMBERS THEY
EXPECT THAT ALLOWS US TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AHEAD OF
TIME. AND THEN IT MAKES FOR A
SAFER EVENT. WE'VE BEEN DOING
THAT QUITE A BIT LATELY, AND
WE'LL CONTINUE TO DO THAT AS WE
RAMP UP FOR THESE EVENTS. THANK
YOU. AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION. AND SENATOR
BRADFORD HAS A QUESTION. I'LL
JUST PIGGYBACK ON THE STAFFING
LEVEL, AS WE JUST SAW IN PARIS,
THEY DEPLOYED 30,000 OFFICERS,
BUT THEY HAD TO SUPPLEMENT THAT
WITH 25,000 PRIVATE SECURITY.
UNDERSTANDING OUR OVERALL
SHORTAGE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WILL WE ALSO
HAVE TO SIGNIFICANTLY,
SIGNIFICANTLY RELY ON PRIVATE
SECURITY TO HELP AUGMENT AND DO
WHAT ALL THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WILL NEED TO DO? YEAH,
I WOULD SAY THAT AS WE MOVE
CLOSER TO THESE EVENTS AND SEE
THE NUMBER OF PERSONNEL THAT WE
HAVE FOR ALL THOSE CRITICAL
ROLES, I'M SURE IT WILL BE SWORN
PEACE OFFICERS. BUT WHERE WE CAN
SUPPLEMENT, WE'LL SEE IF THAT
MAKES SENSE WHEN WE GET CLOSER
TO IT. BUT I THINK AS WE MOVE
FORWARD, WE'LL BE ABLE TO ANSWER
THAT AS WE GET CLOSER. AND I
ASKED EARLIER ABOUT ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE OR AND FACIAL
RECOGNITION, WILL ANY OF THAT BE
DEPLOYED THROUGH YOUR AGENCY?
YES, WE'LL WE'LL BE USING FLOCK
CAMERAS AND OUR LPR READERS
DURING ALL OF THESE EVENTS. AND
THAT'S THOSE ARE REAL SUCCESSFUL
TOOLS THAT WE USE RIGHT NOW. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE PUBLIC COMMENTS.
THIS. GOOD. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. SENATOR BRADFORD AND
DOCTOR WAHAB, CHRIS MICHELI HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, WE
HAVE OVER 1400 MEMBERS EMPLOYING
OVER 650,000 INDIVIDUALS. FIRST,
WE WANT TO APPLAUD THE COMMITTEE
FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING. SECOND
POINT, DOCTOR WAHAB, JUST TO
PIGGYBACK OFF OF YOUR LAST
COMMENTS ABOUT COLLABORATION, WE
DEFINITELY FEEL STRONGLY THAT IN
ADDITION TO SAFETY BEING A TOP
PRIORITY, WE ALSO THINK THAT
THAT WILL BE ACHIEVED BY
COORDINATION AND DEVELOPING A
REGIONAL APPROACH TO ENSURE AN
INCLUSIVE AND SAFE GAMES. MARIA
SALINAS, OUR PRESIDENT AND CEO,
HAS BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY THIS
PAST YEAR AND WILL CONTINUE TO
DO SO WITH REGIONAL AND STATE
PARTNERS ON ENSURING BOTH A
SUCCESSFUL WORLD CUP AND OLYMPIC
AND PARALYMPIC GAMES, AND ALSO A
SUPER BOWL SANDWICHED IN
BETWEEN. SHE WANTED TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY IS
STANDING READY TO PARTNER WITH
ALL OF THESE FOLKS, AND ALSO
THESE GLOBAL EVENTS WILL PROVIDE
AN IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
REGION ITSELF, FROM JOB CREATION
TO INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT.
AND WHEN YOU CONSIDER WAYS TO
ENSURE OUR PUBLIC SAFETY AT
THESE EVENTS, WE WANT TO OR WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO INCLUDE INPUT,
INVOLVEMENT AND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES. WE THINK
THAT THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY CAN
HELP ENSURE THAT SMALL AND
MINORITY ENTERPRISES HAVE ACCESS
TO ALL OF THESE TYPES OF
OPPORTUNITIES. SO AGAIN, WE
WOULD EMPHASIZE THE
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH THAT
YOU'VE OUTLINED. DOCTOR WAHAB,
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENTS?
SEEING NONE I APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S TIME. I DO JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT AGAIN THAT THIS WAS
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING
REGARDING PUBLIC SAFETY. THE
COMMENTS REGARDING ANY BUDGETARY
REQUEST OR COLLABORATION WITH
SMALL BUSINESSES AND SO FORTH IS
OBVIOUSLY DEEPLY OF INTEREST TO
ALL OF US. HOWEVER, THIS IS NOT
NECESSARILY THE FORUM. SO AGAIN,
I APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S
ATTENDANCE. EVERYBODY'S
PARTICIPATION. AND AGAIN, WE
WOULD LIKE A SUCCESSFUL GAMES
MOVING FORWARD. SO THANK YOU.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.